come on
girls
[Music]
soul
St
[Music]
TI
here
[Music]
all
who
[Music]
come on
last
[Music]
paent I
you
[Music]
hello the lag it's not my birthday it
was my birthday yesterday but it's still
pretty much my birthday and this is the
day that I wanted to spend with you guys
so Hi how are you you're doing good yeah
good I'm glad I'm going to wait for you
to catch up with me so I can read in all
your comments but I can see that a lot
of you have made it and I'm so happy
that you're here to spend it with me
yeah this is so awesome so yes thank you
everyone let's say hello to some of you
Bobby Steve Isaac Xavier NY musicals Roo
Ben Ben B
Warrior that's cool
bronchitis um
nikishi all of you guys thanks so much
for coming it's
awesome it's finally happening and look
I got balloons I did have an orange one
too but you can't see it that sucks cuz
it matches my hair should we move it
down no I can't you bothered cannot be
bothered so how are you guys I know a
lot of people couldn't make it or they
can't make it till later on because this
is actually going to be going on for a
while do you want to know what I've got
planned for you okay right so the plans
for today are Q&A right now you guys
just chat to me us just kind of you know
I'll answer some of your questions we'll
just get to know each other for a bit
and then in about an hour's time I've
got my friend coming around and I've got
some
strange Japanese food to try because you
know I'm so original but seriously I saw
it yesterday and I was like I need to
buy this and try it on camera because
just because um I've got it's called
pickled cabbage super noodles so that's
going to be interesting so that's going
to be my lunch today and I'll be eating
that with you guys and um what else then
another Q&A for the people who couldn't
make the first Q&A because you know you
can never get enough of that a few sing
songs and I want you guys to help me
pick out of my games what games you want
me to stream for you later on tonight CU
I'm going to be doing some game gaming
later on tonight on the PlayStation so
that's the plan what do you think sound
fun sound good yeah let's let's just
start with this LOL at the noodles says
Noble Canadian yeah these these noodles
they were too good to pass up I saw I
saw pickled cabbage and I love cabbage
and I love pickled things apart from
pickled onions they're weird so I might
even like them that would be strange
wouldn't it I might even like
them
um did I miss anything Ibraham no or
ibraim no you haven't don't worry don't
worry we're just starting I was just
letting you know what's going to happen
throughout the day and yeah you haven't
missed you haven't missed a thing so
don't don't worry don't
worry so for those of you that didn't
know um my birthday was actually
yesterday but today is the day that I'm
going to be spending with you guys on
the stream uh and over the weekend I had
a brilliant bread birthday me and a few
friends went down to Brighton literally
just a handful of us but I don't even
think you know you don't need a big
group of people and we just spent we
were going to go to Brighton for the day
and we ended up staying all night
getting a hostel and yeah it it was
pretty good it was quite fun but now I'm
with you guys so it's
good audio and video is not in sync ah
sorry about that either oh I was
supposed to take this out as
well I mean either it's this mic which
is pretty good audio or you have um my
my laptop mic so up to you what you want
but the laptop mic is
horrendous so I think we'll probably
just stick with this
one and lazy Sketcher says it's good so
yeah we'll stick with this one guys I
have a new mic coming in the post I have
a new mic coming in the post I'm so
excited um it's I think it's one of
those snow snow snowballs s snowballs oh
yeah I just I know I know everything
don't I no I don't I I'm getting it from
um on Twitter they're called the Apex
Hound so thank you very much a little
shout out
there
so let's start with the Q&A shall
we yeah let's do
this the hum is real oh yeah there
because strangely enough with these
little with these little little
microphones if you leave your laptop
plugged in there's a hum but if you take
out the charger there's no hum so I just
remember to take it out hopefully the
hum's gone or a lot quieter
now
um it's only by like one second or so oh
that's okay then one yeah that that's
okay I
mean yeah I don't know the the one that
comes with the laptop is absolutely
rubbish but Justin no I didn't I didn't
have any gifts but that's okay when you
get when you get a bit older gifts
aren't really a thing uh on
birthdays although my parents are going
to help me uh with a new camera so
that's going to be good and also I I
guess the microphone's a bit of a
birthday gift isn't it it seems like it
so yeah I can't wait to get that
microphone it should be here within the
next few days like yeah can't wait can't
wait so how have you been you you had a
nice day and everything
yeah um talking about do do you got cake
for your birthday I did get cake I got
onion cake it wasn't an actual onion
though I um oh that was Michael by the
way who asked me about cake it was a
cake with brownie on the bottom caramel
in the middle and then sponge on the top
with coffee icing
damn it was good there's still one slice
left so if anyone wants it claim it now
claim it
now um JC doing College work oh no oh
that sucks but you'll get it done do it
do it good I believe in you I believe in
you it's a birthday party oh you asking
me if I had a birthday party Christian I
I kind of had a birthday party we went
to Brighton spent the spent the whole
weekend there it was is really good
Brighton's amazing have you guys been I
want to live there so badly I know
that's where like every YouTuber lives
and that's not why but you know it's
just an absolutely amazing place to be
it's by the Sea um it's not too hectic
like London but there's something always
going on and yeah I just love to live
there I just want to be back by the sea
I miss the
sea the cake is a lie no the Cake's not
a lie wait me Connie an onion cake I
guess that's a lie cuz it's not really
an onion cake it's just got layers
so your birthday poem won't fit too many
characters a noble Canadian you want me
a birthday poem thank you send send it
to me over Facebook or email or
something I'll definitely read it I'll
read it out on um out on here if you
send it to me let me know in the
comments and then I'll read it out to
you
live thing about Brighton is very
expensive parking spaces yeah that's
true actually so all the all the streaks
are pretty hickley pickley as well
they're quite they're quite small which
is really cute I like
that no any musicals just looked at your
subs I've been substance 5K you've grown
so fast yeah it was mental I had like
10,000 people coming overnight and now
I'm like ah not going to lie it was
really scary like really happy
obviously sorry if you can hear the
helicopter s sounds like it's going to
land right next to my
house but yeah it was kind of scary cuz
then I was like I need to make really
good content and I'm scared that you
won't like it but then I was like you
know what you just subscribe to me
because you liked me and I just got to
be myself
tonight thank you Wesker thank you thank
you thank you if my birthday was
yesterday just so you know I'm not going
to pretend that it's my birthday today
but if this is my birthday live stream
kind of for my birthday yesterday cuz a
lot of you guys joined the live stream
last year cuz I had a a birthday live
stream last year as well and yeah you
seem to really enjoy that and then you
asked for it again this year so I was
like why not because I'm doing a lot of
live streams recently but I'm doing
mainly gaming ones so it's nice just to
sit down and actually chat with you
instead of um screaming at game although
that's really fun as well so
yeah
the other one is creepy though what
other one oh muhab the painting behind
you is nice and then Justin says the
other one's creepy yeah this I bought at
little um sale thing and then this one I
actually Drew this is Tera if you
haven't seen who is Tera video yet watch
the who is teror video it's a little
watch it before bed it's a little
bedtime bedtime story kind of kids
bedtime story so you might like it you
might like
it uh sad said sorry why are you saying
sorry lazy Sketcher the chat wasn't as
active uh last year I wonder why yeah
last year how many subscribers did I
have the last birthday it must have been
like 3,000 maybe
1,000 it was I think it was around 1,000
actually my my voice is progressively
going higher but yeah I think it was
about 1,000 which is absolutely crazy a
n musicals has to go your final exams
start tomorrow thank you for coming
anyway so glad you managed to make it
and good luck for those exams I believe
in
you hey you Jenna thank you for the
happy birthday
message okay right so what I want to do
is answer questions so I'm going to be
answering the questions in the chat now
and yeah get your questions ready put
them down put them down if I don't reply
or don't respond write it again later on
so I can see it later on okay so
Muhammad has asked me a question saying
how's your study are you going to make
more raspberries more raspber projects
um I do have the raszi pie now so it's
mine to keep and I do have some
um ideas for sorry the noises they just
come out um I have some ideas for more
razy pie projects I actually
saw um I got inspired by Kick the PJ he
made this like video ages ago about
making a cloud and I was like that would
be cool and how cool would that be to be
in your bedroom as well um and then if
you could connect that to a razu pie and
then connect that to little um strip of
LED lights right and put the LED lights
inside the
cloud um you could then hook that up to
Wonderground which is a an RSS feed of
the weather and depending on the
temperature and whatever of the weather
you can make it go different colors so
it would be like you actually plucked a
cloud from the sky and put it in your
bedroom and you wouldn't need to check
out your window to see what the weather
was like you just look at the color of
the cloud how cool would that be so I'd
like to do that um when I get some Spare
Time
next Robo says it's weird watching the
yagman X stream that's not late at night
yeah I'm kind of night hour guys
although I still wake up early so I'll
go to bed at like 4:00 in the morning
and I'll wake up at 9:00 what no I need
sleep um oh yeah that's a good question
uh eug Jan eug Jan Peri I'm really sorry
if I say names wrong says how old am I
now okay I hate telling this to people
because I know I look a lot younger but
I am
23 oh my gosh I feel old every year I'm
like
you know I'm one year older I I need to
do I need to spend my years wisely but I
think I spent 22 really well actually
yeah I did yeah because I did the Razzy
pie program um I qu I quit my job but it
was good thing because I I got I got um
I got what I needed from the job that
sounds really bad like I met loads of
friends it was amazing I was a web
developer and it was awesome but then I
kind of realized what I wanted to do and
what I didn't want to do and I knew my
path so that's when I went to University
so yeah it was good it was
good um is there still a hum I thought
the hum had stopped if the hum's bad
then I'll have to put on the default uh
microphone but you guys might might hate
that even more so we'll see let me know
if it's just Roo that hates it
immensely
um with the same age oh my God sad is 10
sad every year counts you're still young
Make It Count Make It
Count hi I'm a serial killer want to be
my
friend
uh uh yeah sure why not you can never
have too many
friends um but um oh wait what no I'm
not going to read that
question Romy it's the first time I see
you oh really have you have you never
seen any of the videos before well thank
you for joining the live stream check
out check out my other videos if you
want to you don't have to but you know
you
do
um oh no okay the humming is bad okay
let's have a look at
how how this is then you might hate this
even worse though I'm just
saying okay this is my built-in
microphone guys
it's up to you which one I keep cuz my
my well not mine a lovely a lovely
person is sending me a microphone but at
the moment I have I have this thing and
I have obviously the thing that comes
with my computer so let me know if this
is better or worse and I'll switch back
if it's
worse oh muhub says he didn't hate the
hum that much you guys I don't
understand
you um
Muhammad greetings from Egypt awesome it
must be so hot over there I'm thinking
it's hot here and it's only like
18° uh no it's not so bad which which
one do you guys
prefer the how the audio be last time
Romy says it's better or the audio this
one we can hear the outside the
outside what's the outside
thanks
Jack for the birthday wish did you get
any cool presents Nah when you get when
you get over the age of like 18 presents
aren't really a thing for for birthdays
but I am getting a microphone sent me
which I'm so excited and I guess that's
kind of a rly present and I went to
Brighton for the whole weekend so I am
not complaining it was
amazing this is the worst oh no it's
worse the other one okay I'm changing it
back cuz most people say the other one's
better I'm just going to sit here
there's still a weird noise the weird
noise is probably my laptop just being
like so I thought this would make it
better because it's further away from my
laptop uh jub says j j j j 8891 says the
audio sounds
good I want to answer your questions but
I don't want the audio to be
bad laptop microphone is less delayed
more
fuzzy
[Music]
H the other one sounds like it's raining
it's definitely not raining that's got
to that's got to be my um my laptop just
humming
husing
less delayed no head the other one okay
right we've got to have we've got to
have a um a vote on this I'm going to
count on my hands and the first one that
gets to
five of your different comments and the
first one that gets to five so this is
the other microphone and this is my
laptop microphone okay so I'm going to
start reading from
now when you guys catch up with
me
ah Justin says he'll deal with anything
thanks
Justin the other one is better for me
but anything or do that was Florida so
this is the other
one oh Isaac says a Twitter poll but
then that could go on
forever Romy here's your shout
out
less delay much better that's that one
they're both at
four this is an interesting Teresa says
she doesn't
care um the other one here uh stay with
a laptop oh wait no that's the same
person this
one the other one this one oh my
gosh I don't
care this
one
H this one okay I think it's this one I
think it's this one guys we're going to
stay with this microphone which is
actually better for me CU then I don't
have to worry about this cuz I was
worrying that I was going to go cuz you
know me I T my hands so I thought I was
just going to go knock it out all the
way or
something
right so let's get on with the question
I'm going to go I'm going to see if
anyone's tweeted
[Music]
anything
a oh it's so cute Assad says he's in the
hospital with his grandma no happy
birthday and we'll join the stream later
on oh that's so cute I hope your
grandma's okay I hope she's not in there
for any any big reason sad
um hey mantas how are
you oh what I will do for you as well is
I'll close the window if we're using
this one cuz you'll definitely hear
these
[Music]
helicopters okay if you'll be given a
chance to have a superpow what is
it h so I answered this question before
I think in was it I think it was my
first ever Q&A and um I actually got an
email about it and they asked me to talk
about the email so let me have a look I
said in my previous
Q&A oh no I get too many emails a day I
I get really confused by them there's
too many emails too much
stuff
uh oh
dear oh dear there's so many
emails here we go right it's called
Nicholas
stom um and he was basically saying cuz
I said in my last Q&A that I would want
kind of um the power of knowledge like
to know everything and then he made very
good point basically saying that if you
knew everything there is like no Quest
to life anymore because learning is you
know the most fun thing that you can do
with life when you're not very good at
things you learn to get better and
that's you know that's the point of life
and I totally agree with that and I
think I should probably change what I
said in my Q&A and it's not that I want
to know everything it's that I want to
be able to store everything that I've
learned and not lose it because I'm a
person who has a lot of different um
hobbies and passions and things like
that and I want to try and learn it all
because it all fascinates me so much but
once I start specializing in one subject
area I kind of lose the knowledge of the
other subject area because you know
that's what you do you stuff in memories
and then others come out and it's like
but if I could just retain them all in
here then that would be amazing I could
still learn because I wouldn't know
everything but I wouldn't lose what I
already had in me Noggin you know so I
guess that and that's probably a really
boring superpower
but it's I don't know it's something
that I would
like a photographic memory yeah but then
even with photographic memory they would
lose it after a while wouldn't they you
know it would just be replaced by other
memories that would last I
think
um ooh Vero says check Twitter for a
surprise okay let's have a look at let's
have a look at the
twitters
guys did you make me a little video oh
my gosh I don't think I don't think you
can hear it cuz I don't have the input
in ah wait I want to watch it now I want
to watch it with you okay wait wait give
me one
second is
that I'm going to talk to myself Talk
Amongst yourselves in the chat I'm going
to sort this out so we can watch it
together be so
cool
yeah
okay
oh are you still
chatting
T oh my God look it's popped
up
doie oh I need to move this
way can I use the watch on YouTube's
please
ah don't play yet make it
bigger oh my God it's it's huge now can
you guys see that are you ready to watch
it with
me they're like you'll cry watching
this
I just want to make sure that you can
see it too I'm waiting for you to catch
up with
me live streams just waiting for the
people to catch up with you
brilliant oh it's on Isaac's Channel as
well thanks
Isaac
darn it you can't see me all right
that's fine we'll watch it like this
that was like five minutes of we can't
see you okay how do you start your very
own one I hate my first
video hey telling you how to
survive isn't just a video content a way
that I need
Crea just want to
talk
i
a
control I
[Music]
will I sing such depressing
song
[Music]
hey happy birthday yes man thank you
can't believe I'm doing this but I just
have
to the way you are so engaged with your
audience it's amazing and and you just
deserve the best you always make my day
when when I'm feeling down and thank you
you are amazing never check
I just want to say happy birthday to you
hope you have a great day GI me to
[Music]
you
y
hello um I Amo
at and I'm here to wish you Happy
Birthday and
thank you for everything everything you
do on every single video thank you I
think happy birthday hopeing you're
having a brilant day from yours
Julie oh my
God wanted to wish you Happy Birthday
and thank you I really want to thank you
a lot for making all this wonderful
content on your channel and right to
start my day thank you hey guys man uh
thanks for all the great content you've
been releasing uh loving the new videos
and uh thanks for always training me up
on my down days and happy birthday hello
there good to see you I'm Victor and
today we're going to talk about
potatoes potatoes are everywhere but
what
is oh no no no no
no it's your birthday today right um
well yes um give me a second your today
your birthday so from me and everyone
else happy
birthday you seem to be such an amazing
person so just keep doing what you're
doing you will come
[Music]
far it's awkward isn't
it time goodbye happy
birthday what was a hat made
of
a
guys oh my
gosh sorry to everyone we messed up
thank you so much
everyone a
toast
oh my
God guys that was what that was so that
was so
amazing thank you so much this is like a
live React 2 video now it's it's all
changed oh that was just so a right let
me take this off and
then I will just tell you how how
freaking amazing that
was oh my
god look I don't know that just blows my
mind what what what it's like what I
don't know oh thank you that thank you
that's that was the words that was the
words that I was going to to say
seriously I don't know it's just it's
it's like what I I don't know you start
a
channel uh from nothing
and I don't even usually get like I
don't know yeah I don't want to you
start a channel from nothing and you
like really hope just that you'll
brighten someone's day you know that's
the only reason you do it it's not for
money it's not for fame it's not for
anything it's just because you want to
help other people get happy I don't know
just have an influence on others but in
the most positive way possible and to
see that just kind of confirms like you
did it you did it l you did it I know
I'm not the biggest YouTuber ever or
anything but that doesn't matter as long
as the people that watch me
actually you know get something out of
it and and obviously you guys are
getting a lot out of it if you're
willing to to put a whole video together
for me that's amazing thank you so much
it's so
amazing I just want to watch it like 10
times over now but you guys have already
watched it I hope I hope that that came
out okay you know I hope you got to see
my reaction okay and the audio didn't
plug out or I don't know
whatever it looked like you were okay uh
Ibraham said oh my God that reaction
Victor says high five
yay you guys are funny uh yeah know that
was awesome awesome awesome thank you so
much and I'm just I feel so spoiled I'm
spoiled girl today because yesterday I
had
Essence uh on Twitter she at fses she
made me a little video too you guys are
just I just want to squeege your cheeks
like so adorable H Roman's got to go
thank you
though yes you did it thank you thank
you ah yay you guys are
amazing and Becca's here and she saw the
video yay ah I'm so happy I love this
little Community as well irim I I really
do
uh Roo that this was our first time
watching it as well oh wow Roo um Roo
was one of the dudes the first dude in
that video and he hadn't even seen it
before that's awesome so Isaac did you
edit all of that that's PR good I love
it it's so good thank you so much I I
you didn't have to do that but the fact
that you did means a lot so thank you
thank you thank you thank you amazing
thank you is the place I'm not I'm I'm
I've been knocked off my ball now I
don't know what to do that was way too
emotional for
me lazy sketch's got to go in 15 minutes
no okay uh lazy Sketcher if you have a
question to ask before you go i' be more
than happy to answer as long as this
gets to you before you
leave
um uh oh EMR I do have Snapchat it's
yagman X but do I have to like accept
all of you on on Snapchat because I've
got a lot like do I have to add you back
um to get your videos because I've got a
lot a lot a lot so maybe I need to go
through that very
soon
um oh romy's like I'm staying I can't
miss that live stream a thank you so
much gentleman's like I'll go drink some
Peach why what what is that referring to
I don't know I don't know my brain is
frazzled right
now thanks Laura for the birthday
wish so
happy and bonai just says seeing you re
like that makes us happy I'm glad I'm so
glad I didn't expect
anything um yeah
is is cool it's very very cool it's so
cool this
is now there are no words that is the
thing when you make a professional
Rambler speechless you know you've done
something
right so well done thank
you um oh J says I can get a video from
non-id people how does that work then I
need to look into this SnapChat thing I
mean I use it but I it used to be
personal and I've just kind of opened it
up to you guys so I need to know how to
do
this you always make earth videos now
it's our time to make you a video thanks
vixa you're awesome you're all so lovely
so
lovely she seriously just tickled the
blue
ball M tickling these balls okay it's my
birthday I can do what I want shut up
it's not my birthday it's my birthday e
it but shut up I can do what I want is
my
birthday no it's not it's my birthday
stream okay that's the
thing um okay yes I'm going to answer
some questions because very soon it's
going to be the time for me to eat my
dinner my well my my lunch which is the
pickled cabbage Japanese
noodles so that'll be
interesting
um what's uh Noble
Canadian what are you you afraid of the
most and posted poem on your
Facebook o okay I'll read your poeen in
a second Noble Canadian um so what am I
most afraid
of okay actually this is a really
strange one but I had to face this fear
only this weekend I am scared of
anything touching my feet you know the
feet you know the ridge in your foot the
ridge that goes in like this I just have
it in my head that it's I know it's not
I know this is irrational but I have it
in my head that it's that piece of th
skin is so thin that if anything touches
it especially something sharp like a
rock it could just go straight through
the skin and if anything touches it even
if I touch it with my finger I'll just
be like it's cringing because I just
think it's going to go oh and I went
swimming uh this weekend and swimming in
Rocky rocky shores is the worst Because
unless I've got my shoes on I am it's my
literal it's my nightmare and so I had
to get my friend to to carry me to the
sea and then when I came out I was I
collapsed and I was crawling because I
hate the feeling H just no I can't do
it um bronchitis piot cabbage isn't that
kimchi it might be it might be I don't
know I'm not very good with all that
stuff but but I will be eating it and
I'll have rafar over as well so my
friend rafar is going to come I'm
cooking her lunch and we're going to eat
on the live stream so yeah it's going to
be good I've got some other Japanese
snacks as well to try all right
or thank you for coming to the live
stream
goodbye
goodbye f fola fola do you like your job
do I like my
job um I don't really have a job but I
do I do I'm trying to make my job
something that I love I I've got this
stupid hippie dream in my head that if I
just follow my passions everything will
be okay and
I'm yeah I just want I want to work for
something a cause that I believe in uh
something I feel passionately about
so I'm hoping that you know this YouTube
channel will help me gain that and I
think it really is this YouTube channel
has opened a lot of doors for me it's
amazing and I'm not talking about money
I mean I do a lot of things for free
maybe I should stop doing that but you
know I really just want to make a
difference to to the world oh my God
hippie speak hippie speak but um yeah
for what I do you know this YouTube
channel um doing some freelance work as
well meeting up with some companies next
week actually um helping them understand
uh audiences and how to engage with them
and perhaps the best ways to to use
video format within that and also using
technology to kind of merge that with
videos make it more essive and engaging
but you know for the right reasons to
help entertain you guys to make you
happy but also maybe to help help others
um that find things difficult you know
find it difficult to understand emotions
or things like that I think technology
and arts and video can really do that
help bring people together and really
make a difference but blah blah blah
stop it y answer the question if you
mean if by that you mean my job then yes
I love it even though I don't really get
paid so I don't think it's really a job
but I love it so
yeah um are you religious that's an
interesting question on omr or or
because not really religious now but I
went to an all girls catholic school
when I was younger and I was really
religious I had uh the rosary beads I
used to go to church a lot I I had my
Holy
Communion um but yeah I don't
know I don't know I think I think maybe
going to the school maybe think
otherwise I don't know right now I'm not
really sure what I believe in I'm quite
open-minded to many different religions
I'll gladly listen to anyone talk about
their religion cuz it's interesting so
yeah that's
that um oh
hello hi hi this is my friend
raparo the time has come guys sorry I
didn't get to answer many of your
questions but if you think of other
questions you need to ask I will be back
later on to answer your questions and
right now we are going to make the
Japanese food so stick around we'll be
back in about 15 minutes with some
Japanese food to try on camera for you
guys so yeah it's it's very far
behind I like what's going
on
hi Victor yay hello
people hello people hello
everybody all right are we going to go
make the food then yeah we're going to
go make the food and we will be back in
about 15 minutes so stick around if you
want to watch British girls try Japanese
oh my
God cuz I'm so
original I see you later guys and again
keep your questions for later on I will
be answering more questions later on in
the live stream see you a bit
bye
sorry we are going to be periscoping I
just thought why don't want Periscope
while I'm up in the kitchen so I'll
Periscope and yeah if you follow me on
Periscope look out for me there see you
in a bit
bye
here she
comes here she comes again we've got our
food our Japanese food thank you for
waiting those of you that did really
appreciate it um thanks for waiting so
what Japanese food our two British girls
going to try it again let the noodle
soften before eating it that will take 5
minutes yeah 5 minutes it'll be about 5
minutes very soon so we can [__] these
first so what we've got we've got um
some what was it pickled cabbage noodles
that are just cooling down and I
definitely made them wrong so this is
they don't smell great extremely
extremely interesting um we've also got
this aloe vera which rafar said supposed
to be really good for you or something
yeah I guess maybe I don't know sounds
good uh we got this I don't know know
what this is heas been picked it out so
yeah this is jelly with um kiwi and you
can see that they have seeds in them yep
so it's interesting it's very
interesting
and do we have anything else yeah we do
where are they're behind
you so yeah PE snacks I've heard a lot
about these apparently they're supposed
to be like pretty healthy and pretty
good I don't know so first things first
should we try the PE next Nina shut the
[__]
don't
no
oops what what I'm going I'm just going
to
send Nina stop being mean Nina stop
being
mean guys don't worry I know Nina she's
one of my closest
friends all right so
okay should we try peut yeah sure
okay is that how you
open tear
here I can't normally tear I don't have
those right you grab one and I grab
one oh there's more I thought they'd be
I thought they'd be bigger I'm
terrified you are you going to
yeah they're nice they're actually
really nice they don't really taste like
anything
actually yeah actually like them what do
you think yeah the after tast PE I saw
yagman drink beer I'm peris the other
day was so cute dangly no Canadian I was
dangly dangly drinking my beer it's only
CU I'm short they are really good these
are really good I don't know about
really good oh I mean they're not gross
but they're not
good okay so that's the Pea snack I I
say yes I like them they're
right let's wash it down oh wait no
let's wash it everything down at the end
be around cuz we we know this is
probably going to taste good I don't
know um jellies now or noodles jellies
okay I don't think I want to try the
noodles you have to try the noodles I'm
scared of the they're so excited for the
noodles because they know we're going to
think they're
gross I know yeah that's why I know
we're going to think they they're gross
cuz cuz I made them wrong so even if
they were supposed to be nice I made
them wrong
if you were just on the
par you going hurt their ears what's up
I don't like how it
looks why the Little
Seeds they've got little seeds in them I
don't like it looks creepy it looks
creepy looks like fish
eggs they look creepy
they look
creepy I'm scared I'm
scared oh oh wow it's filled to the
brim filled to the Bri I can't open my I
just broke the opening
bit trying to
yeah this
looks oh my God stop screaming sorry
yeah you got to stop screaming cuz
you're going to hurt
them all
right or I could always turn it turn the
microphone down but then I've got to be
on your level of loudness okay I'll just
turn it back I'll turn it down just a
little
Tad it's leaking it's leaking it's
leaking show the camera show the camera
show the camera I don't want to
show it looks creepy it's not cre I'm
not I'm not looking at it I'm not going
to look at it I'm just just join what is
that food James this is this is kiwi
jelly goodbye to
youi H what's the that there is nothing
wrong with this it just tastes like
jelly no I don't even like jelly that
much I'm still eating it more than you
no no I'm f with that how are you going
to be with this cabbage but
okay this cabbage my audio has decreased
drastically in a
second okay
let's this is what you've all been
waiting
for it smells like
cabbage
I don't want
can that does not look
good
okay let's try it oh my gosh it's so
watery I think we put too much water
these noodles have gone very noodly
though
you got to try a bit with the cabbage on
it for get a bit with cabbage you have
to that cabbage was dry like two seconds
ago no it wasn't it's always been wet
it's pickled it's pickled you put wet
cabbage in that yeah it was pickled so
it's in a little little container but
it's pickled oh no it's Tage oh
no Stir It first we
are maybe she will like the noodles I
doubt it
who said that a Victor I rarely like
things like she doesn't like jelly I
don't think like
noodles's like Yas will like Yas you
probably will I probably
will I like these seethrough noodles and
I love pickled things oh yeah you love
pickles I love pickles so much it's like
so take some of the Cabbage I don't want
the cabbage
yasine wait I'll take some of the
Cabbage I'll try it you need to okay I'm
doing it just for just for your live
stream we're like um in the Disney the
lady in the [__] I'll be the [__] now
I want to be the Trum okay
cool not going to fight okay
okay I'm scared I'm scared
y
no it got
wor that a half bad you know the
aftertaste is bad the aftertaste is
funky it's a bit
spicy H where my I kind of like it no
all right
let's I don't think I'll finish it let's
try this next but I don't mind I need to
get that aftertaste I'm not picky at all
meat right okay this is mango and I
think you should have it first you need
it cuz your your mouth is like full of
tastes that you don't enjoy who eats
noodles with a fork
though people who don't know how chop
Chopsticks I I can use chopsticks I
don't I don't own Chopsticks though just
when I go to japanes
restaurant is that good it's good you
might not like it though can you imagine
if you thought like it remember
yesterday we had uh Ben's like slurpy
juice yeah but the bits it's got bits
does
it
cool I do like that Ben's was way too
sweet it was yeah one of his kids oh
this is good
[Music]
good that was two British girls try
Japanese
Foods I'm just drinking it cuz it's so
good that is
good dad goes like finally Rari liked
something yes yes Andy says we should
use pencils that's actually a really
good idea use pencils as Chopsticks
didn't think of that you could do but
like you could also just go out and buy
chopsticks Noble Canadians like be a
non-conformist eat noodles with anything
you want including fingers not if
they're hot not if they're hot noodles
though you could they're like well not
if they're really hot but if they're are
like kind of warm
just bur
fingers bur your
fingers I eat noodles with my feet gross
Sushi I Love Sushi I love sushi too
Sushi's great I think everyone's tried
Sushi haven't they yeah well not if you
haven't then where have you been but our
Sushi is probably not proper
sushi original Green we should have got
the original one we just thought just in
case you'll get mango we get mango
because
that will masks the taste of
everything we should try ketu ketu I
think that sounds like something I've
tried from they tast yeah the um s wers
is it WG mamas like Catu Curry yeah it's
like got chicken and rice you can get um
vegetarian version oh yeah yeah at yeah
yeah oh yeah I've had it before oh yeah
um oh yeah of course of course I need to
check my Facebook messages all right
um
what you going to check it on your phone
or I eat noodles through my nose just to
be original I wish we could have food
fight on chat you can use the food
emojis are there any food emojis
here
I'm going to look no come on food
emojis oh god oh never mind my computer
is so slow I'm not even going to try
don't
even who is that in the background this
guy he's Terra have you seen who is Tera
yet the video I'm going to talk about
this all day you haven't seen it you
haven't seen it check it out it's really
good where's lot lot somewhere around
just chilling you know
[Music]
put that jelly
away put it on there because it looks
super
gross okay I'm going to go on my
Facebook and see what you guys are
saying what are they say and then I'll
I'll go on Facebook see what you guys
are saying and then I'm going to have
another little break just so I can
actually eat some proper food and then
I'll be back answering some more your
questions and singing some songs for you
oh you going to sing songs yeah you're
going to sing some songs live oh that's
I think I've done that on YouTube yet
actually I always sing songs on
Periscope after yeah I always sing songs
on Periscope and I do it after gaming
live streams but I've never just come on
here and sing songs for you a are you
going to sing them all your original
original music mhm so cute mhm Originals
there they are they're having the food
by yeah
started someone has got a lot of pizza
to be thrown away why would you do why
would you throw away P you throw pizza
away that was Florida D Barella I suck
at pronouncing names I'm so
sorry who what's the name of your friend
my name's rafro if you didn't know
mhm I once picked up four peanuts
stacked on top of each other with
chopsticks that's actually really really
like that's a
talent that is a talent she's going to
sing in Japanese are
you I I am not that that
talented I am reading it from my phone
is s I'm just getting it up tato
fight Facebook Facebook pages sucks on
noile just um turn off Wi-Fi use the
data no it's not bad it's I need to get
the Facebook P oh they don't want to
hear this but yeah the I never get
that's why I take ages to reply to your
messages because I can never get it up
on my stupid phone it never
loads okay let me get up on here I love
ra far I love you too
Robo
[Music]
um next question is going to be to get
your number
you going to give them your number I'm
going to leak your
number should I do that no please don't
I won't don't worry I think I'd have to
get a new phone you probably
[Music]
would love you to
fate potato mash fite that would be so
disgusting like imagine mashed potatoes
just being thrown at your
face actually I think no I wouldn't mind
it I would I'd do it oh imagine walking
in mashed potato I'd like that too but
you don't like things touching your feet
no that's fine that's that's not going
to go through my foit it's only things
that are hard so like fingers or rocks
or something that I think can actually
pierce the skin yeah because fingers are
going to pierce your skin no I know I
know I know I know it's not going to but
it just feels like it is but obviously
if you walk on my it does feel like
but that feels worse it's like
marshmallows yeah that's better than
mashed potatoes cuz they don't go in
between your
toes between okay let's read these
messages on Facebook yeah
yeah and it load what's that picture
behind your friend spooky it's Terra
it's Tera it's from Tera it's from one
of my most recent videos it's called who
is Terror it's a little bedtime story so
watch it before you go to bed
a oh go
away too many friends um oh
cute so
good wait I need to show them this oh no
Thomas ni Thomas Nik do you have Twitter
could you tweet that to me and then I
can show you guys on here and also I'll
retweet it on Twitter as well that's
great this picture that he's drawn to me
is so good so good so
good
[Music]
oh it's so
cute Taco is like poker foot don't say
that t I'm not going to I don't like
feet so I'm not going to be touching
anyone's foot like don't worry I hate I
hate feet
Ki
oh it's such a good picture yeah if you
have if you have Twitter Thomas Nico
please tweet it to me I will retweet it
and I will show you guys on the live
stream right now because I can show you
through through the Twitter feeds CU
it's amazing and I will be showing it
later on anyway so thank you so much for
that I've also got um a
poem I think someone said they wrote me
a poem poem yeah what about you said
they sent it to me on Facebook
I um
no it's not
here it why is that blank oh there you
go it just takes a while
to no it's not here or maybe there
wasn't a poem then maybe it was just
that maybe may it was yeah so thank
you you're offending all the foot fets
well they they can have footes as well
but we can't we just can't deal with it
no I'm sorry
I'm sorry okay let's do let's carry on
with the live Q&A and then I'll get
myself prepped to singing some songs
with you would you like that some
songs where you from We're from England
right by London but not quite London
just of it like an hour away or
five somewhere between
there I'm from Costa Rica oo that's
fancy that is cool that's
cool oh I'm getting so many tweets today
yay you guys are meant to be friends one
doesn't like feet being touched and the
other one doesn't like touching feet
yeah pretty much mhm although it would
be kind of weird if I just had a friend
and they were always like let me touch
your let me just like Gabby touches feet
really yeah why she tickles feet no no
no no no
I would not be okay with that thanks
snow for the birthday wish my birthday
was actually yesterday I'm not going to
lie but I still really appreciate it and
this is my birthday live stream so you
know it's all good man your exam on
Thursday good luck good luck I believe
in you you can do this you do this Romy
do you remember me yes I remember you
you're on most of my live streams don't
you uh does anyone need some sacred gold
potato power what does it do I don't
want to sign a contract for anything
until I know exactly what it does I
don't know what do you want for your
birthday I want a camera a good
microphone and a really good PC
please I do want that but I'm going to
get I'm getting a microphone sent to me
anyway he sent it like 10 times but it's
going to be really good
um I'm from Zac and oh cool cool oh wait
I'm seac I'm from I'm an Armenian
Armenian the name is Sak yeah they're
Armenian got you and they're a fan and
they say
congratulations thank you can't believe
that was two months ago now it's so long
ago what the PewDiePie shower that's
what he was saying congratulations to
yeah that was so long
ago will you be going to
what's insomnia insomnia I don't even
know what that is sounds good who is it
that asked that oh it's going going
to do you speak any language besides
English speak the tiniest amount with
Spanish CU I did learn it in school but
not not the not not very much just the
tiniest little bit Nina wants us to
bring vitamins well Nina knows vitamins
isn't here Nina knows vitamins in Norway
so I don't know why Nina's asking for
vitamins
Nina uh what should have lost that cam
you should have lost the camera no Andy
you shouldn't steal things stealing
bad which is the most favorite video
game character that's Wesker Albert and
which video game character would you be
if you are in a video game H oh that's
really tough I mean the first one that
Springs to mind is probably Paige no not
Paige what I'm talk about Jade from um
uh Beyond Good and Evil just because
that was the first game I proper fell in
love with as a kid and she was just a
kickass girl and she was wearing green
lipstick and that was pretty cool but I
don't know if I'd want to be her but
that's probably maybe my favorite just
because of those reasons don't know who
I'd want to be in
game I don't know I can't think
I have to think on that one I don't know
hey yagman do you play online on
PS4 uh yes I have done I can do I do
have PS4 I'll be playing the PS4 tonight
by the way guys later on I'm going to
ask you guys to help me decide what game
I should be playing that fun I'm looking
forward to that playing some play some
games try American accent please try
American that's laet TR do yeah
[Music]
um I don't know what to say
um oh I'm really sorry I'm going to be
so offensive I'm going to be so
offensive what are you going to do
like I'm just going to do one of the
cheerleader girls cuz they're like the
easiest thing to do all right go for
like probably California or something I
don't La I don't know La I don't know
what they do la cheerleader she says
apparently this is how she thinks they
sound go
on no it's going to be so bad it's going
to be
good was
screaming oh my God so like the other
day I went to go get a bagel and you
never guess who was in there but like
Danny you know like Danny yeah I know
Danny yeah but like then uh we kind of
locked eyes and I thought he was going
to say hi but but he didn't like why not
he literally looked straight at me
passed me and then walked right past me
they don't pronounce the te's like that
you said l you said you said literally I
can't do more like literally literally
Lally you're being so annoy really C
you're being so annoying I'm really bad
I'm really bad I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah mod we read the comments that
was we were doing that because someone
asked us to do American accent so we're
definitely reading the comments we are
reading we would not be doing that if we
hadn't read that comment how is the
weather there here in Sicily is very hot
it's 18° I would say it's very hot here
here too but it's probably not compared
to it's like 18° but we're like oh my
God it's really hot but like compared to
other places it's kind of cold 18°
Celsius not for us 18° Celsius not
Fahrenheit don't know what it is in
Fahrenheit I was going to rate your
American talk with and I remembered I'm
from Texas my dream is
died I went to Texas one I still can't
do it a Texas accent but yeah I did go
to Texas it was cool down there was
really cool I went to Austin and oh my I
love Austin it was amazing it was just
so good ah so good we caned down stream
oh it was amazing still Thanks James for
the birthday wish hope everyone's having
a great day I hope you're having a great
day too thanks for everyone for coming
in and watching this live
stream say something in Spanish uh to um
to s
Bonita it to s Bonita don't even know
raar talking Spanish nina you know can't
you're like my translator so come back
here come and
translate
waiter or is it I don't know I don't
know I can't help I can't
yeah I'm like I'm like I can't help you
as I can't help you um I don't know
every time see are you mommy's like are
you kidding me 18° it's nearly 45 here I
we told you it's probably not hot but
we're not used to that we don't get 45
degrees in England the hottest it'll get
to is like 30 if you're lucky and that
will be an hour one day that's like
everyone's like oh my God there's going
to be a heat wave this week it's going
to be 30° and we're like oh my gosh
we're going to die mhm
yeah I can be a teacher I'm from Costa
Rica we speak Spanish come be our
teacher
oo Texas is part of us but other people
say we have the suest accent really I
don't know I I think all your accents
are interesting I can't do a Texon
accent I I don't know why you would say
someone has a crap accent how do you
have a crap accent you just have an
accent I don't understand people who
don't think they've got accents because
every one's got an accent do people
actually think they don't have accents
some people some people are like oh my
God I don't have an accent I'm like yes
you do where you're from it's why you're
accent that's
it Roo's like I love the video where you
asked tries to pronounce Dutch words yep
that was with MAA Jamila that was an
interesting video
indeed yep what would happen if you
visit here
45° oh well I've been to Malta before
and it's been 50 degrees and I didn't
even have air conditioning in a room it
was horrible I had to I was telling you
about it yeah I had to have cold showers
I would I would just spend every day in
the sea cuz I love swimming but I would
have cold showers before I went to bed
still be dripping wet and try and fall
asleep wet
because yeah if you let yourself dry
then you would just heat up and there's
no chance of you getting to sleep
horrible I can't sleep when it's really
hard
what would you do going back and change
the past or go to the Future and see
what happens Wesker I'll go to the
Future definitely future because
honestly life's already happened like
the past is the past you know just let
it go I want to see what's going to
happen well no not see what's going to
happen to me but I just want to see the
future as in a future that I won't be a
part of I want to like have a little
glimpse of that and that's about it I
don't I want to see my future cuz I
don't want to know you've totally
changed the question so you don't want
to see your future or your past you want
to see a future where you're already
dead yeah with that's a very good answer
I don't know if that can be an answer
but I would go with that one too or I
would go with see in my future actually
because when you change your past you
never know if you're going to change it
for worse or good and as long as if I'm
as long as I don't cross past with
myself and totally mess that up then go
into the future you can't really change
anything you would just gain more
knowledge so it would give you a chance
to actually alter it so like your
actions now you know like may affect
what you saw so exactly you know you
might change that it would be more
beneficial for you yeah you can see
what's maybe wrong with the world and
try and change it and stop that now or
maybe it's something wrong with your
life or something that you don't like
and then you make sure to take actions
not to do that we we're taking this
question serious again yeah we're
actually think thinking like we got
given this opportunity and we're like
okay so what should we do I don't
know um H Would You Rather game Rather
game what right now no I'm I'm good just
chatting to you I will be gaming tonight
though so if you find this boring come
back later on and I will be playing a
game so that's cool and I'm going to be
playing some songs for you in a bit as
well I'm getting a bit hungry though so
I'm probably going to have to take a
little break hunger break but I'll leave
the live stream of the Twitter feeds
running so you guys can see that yeah
mhm fish or meat well I don't eat either
but fish fish fish is the only thing I
miss actually well I don't know it's
like asking me salmon or chicken both
I'll take both both both I'll just have
same time I'll just have
both wow Andy that's deep yeah Jonathan
Peterson it was deep it was a deep
question was deep
uh H how was your day was a really good
day thanks and over the weekend we went
to Brighton and that was freaking
awesome that was so good it was so good
say
it will you sing sweater I will be
swinging sweater are we swinging sweater
I'll be playing sweater later on for
you we have potatoes I don't have
potatoes you might have potatoes in my
kitchen you have your bag of food I have
a pot upstairs too there you go she's
got potatoes I have't I got one potato
sweet a sweet potato if that can sweet
potatoes are the best potatoes yeah if
you don't agree fight me on it they are
they are the best potatoes and jao's
like how are the burgers yesterday they
were good were they were good we had
Burgers yesterday and they were very
very good Pepsi or Cola I don't like
either I don't do well with fizzy drinks
they make me gassy a
I like
Cola
um did you have a chicken no but I want
a chicken a chicken I think I tweeted
about wanting a chicken did you get your
chicken yet oh yeah how's we going to go
we should we can't get a chicken it's in
the contract we we've just got a new
house guys but it's in the contract it's
in the contract we can't have a chicken
animals lizards or fish we're not
allowed we're not allowed them sucks as
pets we're not actually we can have a
chicken because like he didn't say
anything about chicken and he he an
animal yeah but like no does he care if
it's alive because people have chicken
in their homes a
lot so that's not in the
contract that's not in the contract when
you say I bought a pack of eggs and it
hatched what to do with it so we kept it
it would [__] everywhere chicken shits
are so
runny we'll keep it outside are you a
cat person oh let's go back up are you a
cat person oh I can't see who wrote that
or a dog person I can't sorry I've
totally missed who wrote that comment
but someone said are you a cat person or
a dog person I I'm an animal person yeah
like I love all animals um but I guess
you had to choose I'm more of a cat
person because I've only ever had cats
my mom was really allergic to dogs so we
could never get a dog but yeah so I grew
up with cats I had cats throughout my
whole life until they died and now I
don't have
cats I like puppies and
dogs dogs I love huskys I want a husky
right now I just love animals although
with dogs I prefer the big dogs the big
dogs that you can like
properly you know like
yeah cuddle
be yay Bella hi Bella thank you for the
little video that you made it was so
cute it was lovely would you rather be a
Jedi Knight or a
wizard that is a really tough
question actually um I don't know may
maybe a wizard because surely if you're
a wizard you could just wish up the
force anyway right no you got I don't
think that's a thing you can wish off
well the magic is pretty much the fourth
anyway the fourth anyway so like and
then when you're a Jedi you're just one
thing you're you're a Jedi and you can
wield the force and whatever and you're
you know you're really good at fighting
and yeah but when you're a wizard you
can do whatever you can magic up
whatever and you can I don't know I
could make animal speak I could have it
so that I can breathe underw I could
maybe even Master the the the magic so
much that I could fly there's a lot more
that you could do I think if you were a
witch yeah yeah same thing witches and
wizard mhm yep same I
agree
uh who would you you you be
Oh I thought this in YouTube who would
you be Max CFI or chlo price I would
probably be Max I'm definitely more of a
Max chlo price is way too cool I'm more
kind of reserved even though I know I
don't see my on YouTube but you got to
remember I'm just talking to a camera so
I would definitely be Max corfield and
she is cool she is cool and in a totally
different way to chlo but you know she
she tried so much to save her friend and
I respect that Luke Sky Walker or Harry
Potter I guess we just answered that in
the other question Harry Potter just
because of the things we can do but then
actually thinking about the people oh I
don't know I don't I don't think I'd
like to be Harry I'd rather be May or
Ron or something yeah
true oh
yeah um Bella was screaming bless you a
uh fav
movie favorite movie Submarine that's my
favorite movie it still is it's been for
like three or four years now it's so
good they were screening it in uni what
screening remember doing work yeah my
favorite is stop pilgrim rest of the
world that's a good film to you that a
good film to
you um do you know that British girl B
called Little Mix I don't actually but
I've heard of them I know them because
they were on X Factor I think oh I don't
watch that yeah they were on X Factor
and now they're like a thing they had
one song that was in the charts in the
UK I don't even know but yeah I know off
them because they're like kind of big
aren't they they're like the girl One
Direction mhm yeah well no I don't know
I don't know who they are I don't know
why I just agree yeah you were just like
sure I I've heard of them definitely and
that makes sense if there the girl One
Direction because I don't listen to One
Direction either I think I'm not bit too
old for that don't know no favorite
cartoon it's
probably either cage dog or Invader Zim
or like Ed and Eddie Ed and Eddie I was
going to say Ed and Edie good I really
do like Invader Zim I like the camp
twins too yeah that's so good I and cat
dog C cat dog cat dog alone in the
world oh do you remember Cow and
Chicken Mama chicken mama no wait Dad
had a chicken mama had a cow no no mama
had a chicken mama had a cow D I ask how
she didn't know
how something like that I don't
know
what har Potter is overrated he's
always I read that as hello
tjy is TJ here yeah I think he was up in
the comments
earlier they won the
XA that makes sense MK that makes sense
Bella P what is the meaning of life
don't know the meaning of life is to be
yourself and to live it how you want to
live it so you create your own version
of the meaning of life yeah I mean I was
going to be kind of cynical and just be
like if you think about it there is no
meaning sh no but there isn't and that
makes that makes life so much better
because there's no expectations and like
everyone everyone's living their lives
trying to find out who they are and who
they should be and whatever but then if
you think about it like there is no end
goal you're just living so just enjoy it
right now you know there is no end goal
there's nothing for you to strive for
whatever life is right now is what life
is does that makes sense so stop stop
trying to be something that you're not
try stop like cutting yourself out from
the rest of the world because you're
trying to work hard for something that
you're not too sure what it is because
that's what I do a lot and then you just
kind of have to remind yourself that
this is life enjoy it right now well um
that became very yeah but I got to
remind myself of that a lot a lot a lot
what is your favorite TV series oh gosh
I don't watch much TV but when I do I
usually just have it on Netflix uh and
I'm editing so I don't really know
what's going on I just have it there
backround noise but I have been watching
ey zombie recently and I really really
like that cuz that was on Netflix oh
yeah I haven't watched that I really
probably should watch that it's really
good
and how
hello yasine stop ignoring me stop IGN
ignoring Ry Ry I ship you to thanks
vitamins thanks
te
um does she have a Channel or no who me
woo yagman
speech yeah do you have a channel raar I
don't have content on my channel I am
follow her on Snapchat I'm a viewer
follow me on Snapchat that's basically
my daily Vlogs it's rafar so get get
your I'll get my little snap code so
open your Snapchat apps if you want to
add me with is more interested than me
she gets out the house a lot so you'll
see more cool Snapchats and you'll see
our little coffee dates cuz we have
coffee dates that's my
Snapchat so you can screenshot or scan
or add me via name do whatever you
want okay so
five
four
three two one and it's
gone gone there you
go Mark I am 23 believe it or not I know
I look about
[Laughter]
12 she
23 hi on Snapchat yeah I know Bella I
see your name I see your name pop up
sometimes and I'm like oh bronchitis
watched your Snapchat yesterday so you
know how much fun Brighton was yeah
Brighton if you saw like the four
Brighton snaps then yep yeah they were
fun they were
fun is that right it is r
uf4 r o so I'm going to type it
on this right now there you go there
there you go that's it sup Lucas sup
dude s
dude Vincent
13 atim AG to be make every year count
you're still so young he 10 years
younger than you so much life ahead of
you 10 years
yeah what is the secret of life it's
pretty much the meaning of life I think
the same answer that we gave to the
meaning of life there is no
it is what you make it it you make just
make sure that life is what it is now
just have fun with it stop worrying so
much don't worry about life yeah it will
sort itself
out # yag potato yag potato yag potato
all right whatever you say what kind of
music do you like I listen to anything
literally if it sounds good to me then
I'll listen to it I don't care about
genres who things it I don't know like I
just I'm influenced a lot by my friends
if they like something and they're like
I'll listen to this and if I think it
sounds good I'm like oh yeah I'll listen
to that you know I introduce you to um
electro swing didn't I yeah I like I
like electric swing I enjoy pop music
chart music hip hop rap R&B like
anything give me country and I'll listen
to it like rock anything you have I will
sing very soon I I'll sing soon going to
have a break soon going to eat some food
cuz I haven't eaten properly since I
don't know since last week no I'm joking
since like very early this morning so I
need to eat some food you need and then
I will come back with my ukulele and
we'll have a little Jam sesh together
guys I'm pretty sure I'm not going to be
able to watch the whole stream because I
need to eat as well too bad
Rob yep yep yeah you guys don't need to
watch the whole stream I totally don't
it's just this stream is so long that I
just expect people to come in if they
want to when they get bored they come
back out and then maybe come back in
later and see what's happening so it's
cool like TJ's leaving cool bye TJ bye
TJ hope no Way's treating you well yeah
hope it's good you'll get some Hager
slav likeo
Bay I don't know how to spell it what
are they talking about do you like
spot no I prefer to play them than to
watch them yeah me too like I don't see
the point in sitting down and watching
it I just want to play it you know yeah
what's your favorite to play though my
favorite to play uh I quite
like don't know like badminton I us
badon a lot it's good yeah my my cousins
used to have a bath thing we used to
play it together yeah that's good I like
basketball to play basketball dodgeball
dodge ball that's fun so F that's
fun would you be would you rather be
able to jump to the moon but have a fork
as a hand or be able to make any food
appear but it's always too sorry uh I
see what you can't see that was asked by
you uh why would I want to jump to the
Moon I can't I can't breathe up there so
I would die instantly I need to get
having having Forks as hand would be not
fun well it would make it extremely hard
to get in my astronaut outfit also you
can't like you can't
bend little fingers I think I would die
so I would say the second one yeah like
you don't have to eat the food that's
too salty by the way and is it salty
because there's salt on it because then
you can brush it
off yeah and you don't have to eat it
because you don't have to eat it you
don't have to eat it yeah if you just
like I do my chips I would just get
chips chips because I love my chips
salty
chips like
chips so that
one would you rather have fingers with
toes or toes to fingers everyone asked
this question from me um I don't I just
don't want anything involving
toes yeah I'm just imagining my so I'm
going to have fingers for toes because I
don't want toes on my hands yeah same
cuz at least you can hide hide your feet
yeah you can just buy like massive
shoes yeah Isaac # logical yard logical
yeah it's like your Wolverine what with
the fork hands yeah not as cool it's
just it's just forks forks are not cool
well they help they're helpful how old
are you I'm 19 I'm
23 woo chips
manx
but if we ever do a Meetup I can just be
like thanks for coming chips chips
thanks for coming chips chips chip
soorry you have to wait for ages chips
chips chip and then they'll be like uh
we don't want salt on our chips like
sorry sorry I can't do anything about it
McDonald's chips
McDonald's um watch
initial Iron Man or Captain America
H um see I'm more of a DC girl anyway
but I probably say I haven't seen the
newest Captain America movie so I'd
probably say Iron Man just cuz he's
pretty cool but then again he's really
arrogant I can't ofno I don't mind
arrogant people
sometimes H maybe I
do maybe I do I don't know I know I
think he's cool so I'll he he is quite
cool he's cool I like the the fact that
you know kind of like Batman he's turned
himself into this would you rather be
dead no would you rather dead or be dead
I don't know what that would you rather
kill Hy that makes no sense that makes
no sense how you would you rather all
your haircuts end up looking like a loaf
of bread or every piece of furniture you
sit on turns into wet
sponges imagine this bed was like a of
wet
sponge that would not be good not fun oh
I got a myth Co from is it important
might
be oh it probably is whatever yeah um
I'm going to have a look and see what a
loaf of red haircut looks like it's
probably not going to be
great to the person who asked um how we
met when met in University so we started
off in the same course but then she
changed and she left me but you know
what we're still best friends so it
doesn't matter you know what you know
what I don't think red hair looks too
bad quite all right so I go for this one
yeah cuz wet sponges are not
fun wet no they're not no they're not
okay guys it's 5:00 I'm going to answer
one last question and then I got to eat
some food and I will be back in about
half an hour or so with my ukulele to
play for you to and I implore you go and
get some food go and make yourself a
nice little drink have a nap naps are
good naps go to the
toilet if you've been watching us in the
toilet it's a bit weird but I'll tell
you
enjoy
um could okay wait which which one
should the last question be um that
[Music]
one oh my gosh gray Turtles that's a
really tough question gray Turtles ask
would you rather live forever or die
right
now oh I'm going to have to say live
forever aren't I because I don't want to
die right now there's got way too much
things to do but living
forever horrible I would die right now
really
yeah like living forever is torture
because everyone around you is
eventually going to die so I will just
die right now because once I'm dead I
won't really care that I'm dead when I'm
dead but like I am to S like the people
around me will be missing me and stuff
um but like i' die right now because you
know I
mean there's a lot to do there's a lot
that I still want to do and Achieve but
like if you live forever how many how
many times are you going to start again
and be doing different things and be
meeting different people and keep
leaving you yeah but then also you could
become if you live forever you could
literally become a superhero your life
my life wouldn't be as what it is now
but all I want to do now is make a
difference to other people and as long
as I knew I couldn't die I could really
really make a difference to other people
I know the life would definitely not be
as nice as it is and I would probably
cut everyone out of my life because I
knew I'd have to say goodbye anyway but
I could just live my life and devote it
to making the earth a better place and I
could maybe be giving myself a death
sentence anyway I don't know maybe I'd
rather do that wow the light is so
bright yeah but you'd be living forever
you can't
die you can try but you won't succeed
you just feel the pain of the death of
whatever's hurting you but like I know
but then at least you had made a
difference cuz no way could you live
forever and not make a difference to at
least one person yeah but like you're
going to live
forever you're going to make differences
probably forever you're going to live
forever till the Earth literally
collapses and that's the end of the
Earth you're going to live till end and
that's scary so I'm going to die right
now there must be a way out of it
there's got to be a clause there's got
to be a way out of it especially if you
do so many good deeds if there is a big
man up
there he's going to take
care know unless I made a deal with the
devil oh unless that person who was that
that asked us that question unless they
are the devil yeah and we
just yeah imagine you literally living
forever and I'm just
like yeah I'm like you're
like um okay I'm going to go now make
some foods I'll see you in about half an
hour's time um yeah and please stick
around if you want to watch you play you
I will leave the live stream the the
live stream going and it'll be showing
the Twitter feeds with the hashtag yag
my next bday so if you want to tweet
with that hashtag you'll see it come up
and yeah I will see you when I come back
bye guys I won't be returning so bye
yeah say goodbye to raal see you it was
fun hated it what the food yeah well it
was fun talking to I hated the food not
them no yeah you already came here to
try some food and you hated all of it I
liked the drink you like the drink but
that's not food these were okay I mean
too
bad they're okay to begin with and then
they turn a bit a it yeah I'm not going
to eat the rest of those either it's not
a thing it's not going to happen it's
not a
thing
okay I'm trying to wait until they catch
up with us so I can see they like bye
far Roo do come back don't listen to
Ramy everyone come back if you can you
don't have to but I would love it if you
did so I would love it if
you they will come back I hope so listen
to the sweet sweet music sweet sweet
music sweet sweet
music right let's say goodbye bye guys
thanks for watching see you later bye
bye everyone bye
bye
[Music]
now
hello guys how are you you all
good I'm back I'm back I'm back I'm back
for those of you that were just in my
Periscope yes I was tuning my ukulele
and then I realized that you guys could
hear the tuning so you were like what is
that what is that noise it was me tuning
I have been reading all the tweets with
the hash yagman xday as well and they're
awesome I love that little scribble who
who who did the little scribble that was
amazing it was really
funny
um why why your dark that that was a
funny funny little scribble that he did
I'll quickly turn over so you guys can
see it's a funny little
scribble okay so hello I'm going to put
on my little light cuz it's getting dark
now cuz I'm in England and uh yeah the
light doesn't stay around in England for
for very
long
so have you all had a nice little break
did you go make yourself something to
eat do some stuff these are things
bronchitis did you see my fan art
bronchitis uh which one was that there
was what the scribble I just spoke about
it was it the scribble was it this
bronchitis
it says hash fan art so it's brilliant
if it's that I think it's
great did you saw the Bugs I feel
embarrassed what
bugs or was it this
one I don't know there's load of little
drawings and they're all
brilliant
oo oh those ones these bugs yes I did
look at these bugs
guys not too sure where the bug was
there but it was cool
anyway oh okay guys before I sing for
you I need to show you um Thomas V
flores's fan art oh my gosh it's amazing
this is the one that he sent me on
Facebook if some of you were here
earlier I I opened it on Facebook and
it's so good look at it look at it look
at it look at it in all of its
Glory how good is that it's so good
ah you guys spent so much time doing all
this stuff it's amazing thank you so
much so awesome just so
awesome Thomas is like that's me yeah
that's you and you're talented and it's
awesome and thank you very much it's so
good so good anyway I am here to sing
some sing some little songs for you guys
cuz that's what I told you I was going
to do I don't know why I had to say
because I will
be
and obviously the first song to start
this off will be sweater because cuz you
guys love sweater I love singing
sweater so it just it just makes a lot
of sense doesn't it so we're going to do
that oh yeah you guys are so lovely
everyone loves Thomas's drawing
obviously how could you not it's
amazing There You Go Thomas if anyone
wants to see more artw well I'm guessing
you do more artwork Thomas I don't know
you have to now cuz they're all going to
be wanting to see some not of me I'm
just saying in general follow him on
Twitter um I just showed you his Twitter
account it's
Trilla Trilla
Flores follow
it
right like sweater
yeah
exciting
okay
I just tuned my ukuleles and you guys
heard that and you got very confused by
it so it should all be ready to go for
you oh Thomas vlores has Deviant Art
this is good I'm going to put my other
pillow
here I can get nice and cofy I would be
horrible singing on a stage because I
need to be comfy and I don't know how
they do it I don't know how they stand
there and do all this I want to be on a
bed I want to be nice and
comfy my little
YouTube PE
snack trying to clean up but whatever
it's
cool
[Music]
I can't wait forever not that patient
I've too
many
[Music]
your
when I won't
[Music]
be SM conceal the secret
so
siet that I can't see the of taking
deeper it's just so
beautiful I don't want to spoil your
soul you don't leave this too go
cold your eyes make me feel dizzy
when you qu me on my childhood his I'll
share with you if you so kindly cut me
so I can
[Music]
see I cry through the so GL straight on
to me but instead I and this you that so
shallowly
and I don't want to spoil my
[Music]
soul please don't leave this to go cold
it's the best things are wor waiting for
you disagree would you only see now
right here is where we both are and I'm
too afraid to turn around and see how
far and see how
far I can't wait
forever that Pati I've got to
many you're comy like
aweer when the comes up I
[Music]
be
hope you liked it you know it's so hard
not to read your comments I really want
to read your comments while I'm singing
but then I know I'll get put off and
I'll make a mistake so I'm like stop
stop concentrate concentrate but now I
can read your comments so I'm going to
read your
comments by the way your beard game is
strong
thanks um I think they're talking to
someone
else
uh what did you guys
think starts giving Grammys oh thanks
Andrew ran ran
ran uh is she reading these comments or
is she on like YouNow n my name I I
don't do the YouNow stuff I don't I
don't get it I don't get you now at all
and I don't want you guys to spend money
ah thank you thank
you you guys are so lovely
favorite song Taco nice
nice still waiting for your album yes I
will definitely be working on that my
album first goes to uh the lovely
patreons though they get it first I need
to do a lot for them um I'm going to
have a whole patreon day where I just do
things for them because they freaking
deserve it so much um yeah and then it
will be available for you guys I'm not
quite sure how I'm going to do it um I
mean at the moment it's going to have to
just
be I don't know I'll sort it out I'll
sort it out
there cuz I also really would love to do
a giveaway when I get money because I've
just bought a new house well renting a
new house so my money
is but hopefully I'll get
some
um yasine did you watch the Eurovision
song contest I really liked England I
didn't fenk that was the night that I
was having my big birthday celebrations
so I was in the pub and I did kind of
see it in the pub but I didn't get to
watch it because as you can imagine pubs
are loud uh people would talk a lot in
the pub so I did see some things you
know you always see crappy people on EUR
Vision but no I didn't really watch
it Robo wants to make my album you can
do
that okay can you do royalty free
ukulele song the 43 you song what's that
I don't even know what that is Aman am
man he Yi Y is lonely I'm not I one
thing about me is that I love my own
company I love being alone that sounds
really weird but I I really enjoy it I
mean I love being my friends as well my
friends are awesome but sometimes it's
just nice to be alone I'm going to stop
talking now cuz it makes me seem like a
right weirdo but I'm sure I'm sure some
of you guys are the same um ah you guys
are like we getting the album thanks
guys that's so cute pubs allow yagman X
2016 very true very true what I will
sing to you now is another new one that
I've been working on and I really enjoy
singing it so I'm just going to sing it
for you um I don't have a name for it
yet um what should I call it don't know
maybe dreams
or inflatable head maybe my inflatable
head maybe I'll call it my inflatable
head yeah that sounds
good all right I'm going to sing this
one for
[Music]
you as I walk down
this Tre I no
have on the
ground and with every step I take my
head up
in till I reach those
CL where my dreams all comes Al life
every day is a
delight you
want to drive me
[Music]
down without a single worry I'll admit
I'm in no hurry to
pass down my
[Music]
hand
flow Where You
Are by every hope and wish that I refuse
dis leaving in the
back as unselfish Wings upwards I fly
and I can't hear you from this height as
you
the
home you just watch as I just throw away
reties I mod like clay but you will I
know
God oh yeah you know I'm no
God if I drift I lose it
all but I can't help it when I hear the
C I'm too scared
to
[Music]
what there you go that's my Lis s
inflatable head my inflatable
head it's funny cuz the comments are so
far behind I've just had to um yeah I
just have to wait until you guys are
here are here with me but hey it's
better than just being a normal video
right cuz at least I can actually talk
to you but
yeah heads in the clouds heads in the
clouds sounds like a great title what do
you guys think heads in the cloud cloud
or my inflatable head let me
know I'm going to open my
carens a bit
more oh that's very that's like
extremely bright it's either really dark
or it's sh
bright
W oh the sun it burns
no oh God was so much better
why do people ever open their curtains
why is that even a
thing I literally hardly ever my
curtains it's really bad actually
probably should but
whatever
um I can't go Periscope because I don't
have an account Andrew get a periscope
account well you don't have to but if
you're on Twitter you might as well
anyway it's it's really good I like
Periscope It's cool cuz also you just
get to see what people are doing for
from around the world and it's not just
a platform like this there are some
people who don't even show themselves in
it but they'll show you cool things from
around the world live it's really
cool
Romy
ow I'm sorry if I'm saying your name
wrong oh thanks for coming Darwin DC
even though you're in class pay
attention pay attention but thank you
thank you very much for coming it's
sonest evil yeah I totally agree with
you this is why I'm so pale though I
need to get T and I that's what people
do oh whatever I I'll get one when I'm
outside I'm I hate sunbathing I hate all
that stuff I can't stay still for that
long I don't know how people do that I
can't just
fly in the sun no it doesn't work it
doesn't
work my name my mom wouldn't let me get
anything but a YouTube that's fair
enough that's fair enough I mean YouTube
is my home so I as long as you're here
with me on YouTube you're you're going
to you're going to hear everything it's
good
um yeah I know Dar and DC you in class
you told me before go back to class but
thank you so much I I'm glad that you
came in stopped by even that you're in
class I wonder does your school have
Wi-Fi is it good my school never have
Wi-Fi um three days oh no that's
horrible comment
uh I'm putting you in a Timeout Missy
FL um the truth has been
spoken when are you finally going to
pronoun my name right it's
FEMA
oh you see my mind just blow a little
bit there sorry FEMA I should stop
calling you
fem unless you want that to be our
little thing you know like can you're
known as feme in in the yagman world but
obviously that's not your real name so
I'll call you FEMA f
f sorry that I got it
wrong what should I sing for you guys
next this is really fun actually I
haven't just sat here and sang to you on
YouTube in a live stream in a very very
long time happy me very
happy sorry I'm moving you
guys okay so what should iing for you
next how
[Music]
about
does any of you guys have any um
suggestions that you want me to sing for
you next or should I just start singing
my next song I could sing magnet you
want me to sing
magnet George Valentin why why do you
look like you cried I didn't cry I
didn't cry oh wait what before before
did someone say that I need to cry
before that was probably because people
made me a video like lovely people you
guys made me a video and I got old teary
about it I got old
teary okay
let's should I play for you
magnet here the noise I saw it I called
it I'll play it I thought you guys were
going to ask me to play that
one
um
[Music]
slow okay you ready for
this I'm going to sing this for
you sorry I'm being like really slow
over sudden I had you you up on a chat
and it stopped the chat stopped it's
okay I can still see you in my in my
other window let me try and get you up
properly please sing sweater Ro I
already s sweater you
guys you're so
funny should I just do a live stream
like a seven hour live stream of me just
singing
sweater I'm getting my microphone soon
and I'm going to properly record sweater
for you I know you guys going to like
that
oh the pop chat's not working oh no it
is no
[Music]
stop here we go all right hear the noise
mve so soft and slow for you right
back
[Music]
hear the noise so soft and
slow that's the sound of freshly fallen
snow your love is
C your love is
C
[Music]
and seems as though we stuck out every
day bang upon these drums that we have
made you never
know you never
know
[Music]
my one my only
one I sing in the
[Music]
sun give
CH nothing brace your St like what's be
[Music]
D the fro wood next to the
sh pile it up so high and paint it
red confuse the
door confuse the
[Music]
door
and time he L resting on the
[Music]
stair the window out reveal cooler
air and so we go
and so we
[Music]
go my one my only
one Twi to keep
[Music]
me
Chas
everything that ends still
[Music]
be inside of my mouth slow
migrations out and if not to
[Music]
beight it's not to
Bey
[Music]
breathe you what do you think what do
you think you like it you like was that
up to up to your
standard was it good was it
good
ah Andy she puts so much emotion while
she sings It's hard to not like the way
she sings oh thank you I I do actually
I'm I'm kind of I'm conscious of that
when I'm s I'm like straining my face
muscles y you guys like it thanks the
colors of these songs the colors of the
song you have colors in a song news to
me I like
it CL flap flap thank you thank you a
you guys are so cute you know what I'm
going to move straight on to another
song I'm thinking if we're going to do
covers I'm
thinking
um either Bon
IA
or what's it called it's hard to get
around the
wind um which is the song that's in my
favorite film called submarine so I
might just think it's hard to get around
the wing cuz that one probably sent you
to sleep
and maybe this one this will probably
send to sleep again but yes I'll do it's
hard to get around the
[Music]
wind I don't know any Fallout boys sorry
goodbye social life I love that name
goodbye social life I'm
sorry
got to get
my where is it where is
it yep I'm just awkwardly looking at
you that's not right that's
right okay
like you're trying to get to heaven in a
hurry and the queue was shorter than you
thought it would be and the doorman said
you need to get a r
friend you got to between the
pitfall wait this is the
wrong one second I'm on the wrong UK
lady tab oh silly me silly me Alex
Turner his name is Alex Turner if you
didn't
miss brilliant musician sarine is a
great film you should you should you
should definitely watch
it get
around I'll s for you while we're
waiting
it's a warm
color
o thanks for coming back by the way I
haven't said it yet so thank you thank
you for coming back I appreciate
it okay this one's
better
it's like you're trying to get to heaven
in a hurry and the C was sh you thought
it be and the doorman said you need to
get a
[Music]
r got to live between the
pit but you're looking like you're low
on energy did you get out and walk to
Ure You' miss the
quick
looking for a new place to
begin feeling like it's hard to
[Music]
understand but as long as you still keep
prepering the
pills you'll find a way to spread it out
again and even when you
know the way it's going to
blow it's
h to get
[Music]
around stretching out your neck on your
evening trying to even out some but it's
sa to multiple
confusion
and you can shriek until your
Hollow or whisper it the other way
trying to save you without putting your
shoes
on looking for a new place to
begin feeling like it's hard to
understand but as long as you still keep
preping the pill you find a way spit it
out
again and even when you
know the way it's going to
blow it's
hard to get around the
[Music]
wind
I can hear you through my
window but I'm never quite sure who it
is they want the world on how
to it always sounds like they're
fighting or as if that's what they're
about to do it might not hurt now but
it's GNA hurt
soon woo the scroll went faster than I
could play the
song thanks guys I'm glad you like
it oh someone says L laet says that's
why I always focus on her lyrics oh why
why are you guys saying about my lyrics
that's good because I do put a lot of
time and effort in my lyrics I think
I've told you guys before that if you're
if you're a songwriter you put your H
everything into the lyrics to make sure
that it's getting the emotion you want
to come across I don't know it's a very
intricate thing but those aren't my
songs they were covers so
yeah um it's about sending a message o
what
is so relaxing like on the beach
yeah oh I don't know the moon song bra
turs I actually don't know the moon song
as in I don't just not know it on youth
Lele I don't know it in real life I
don't know the song but I need to listen
I need to listen to it because it comes
up a lot when I search in new youth L
songs and I'm like I need to find out
what this moon song is um thanks guys
I'm glad you liked
it hashm the quicksand Andy CI CI
CI I can't sing 21 Pilots song because I
don't know it great Turtles I'm so
sorry how about some Bon IA though Bonny
be how do you guys say it do you say Bon
IA or Bonny be you can't really tell me
can you you can write it in the comments
but then I'm just going to read it
however I read it
so
hey shiraj um shiraj say oh I hate
pronouncing people's names wrong I'm so
sorry say rest store my friend knows you
cool who's your friend let me know I
want to find out who your friend is Roo
#7h hourwe
stream maybe I'll do that through
Periscope one time whoa this light is
actually blinding me stop it stop
it let's have a look what I can do with
this the sun moves and it's really
annoying why do you do this to me he's
done okay oh no no it's just all right
time to just not allow the sunning to my
life at
all sun is not
allowed
um trapped
inside yeah I I I don't know the L I
don't know the ca is trapped inside
I I I've explained this before I think
um I was actually really upset that day
and then I came up with that song I sang
it I recorded it and I haven't sang it
since it was all a one day thing it was
crazy but I need to learn the lyrics for
it because then I can play it again
because it was quite a fun song to sing
and I was pretty bad at you clearly back
then so I think I went a bit better now
so son how dare you mantis yes son how
dare you how dare you um
you guys haven't said anything about Bon
IA so I'm guessing you don't want to
hear Bon IA what other songs can I give
you um see I I sing kind of like songs
that most people don't know so there's I
can sing You Are The River by Johnny
Flynn and Laura Marlin that's a really
beautiful song really beautiful song I
can sing you uh Cosmo Javis
song um
I can sing
you I can attempt to sing you where the
world things are song I haven't found
that in a while it could go bad but we
could try it
anyway
[Music]
um you're saying fall I can definitely
do fall I if you fall is something I can
totally do totally do I can sing
Adventure Time too you guys want that
right let's sing Adventure Time For All
You Adventure kind fans out
[Music]
there I don't know why you're say like
that
um okay so apparently goes with this
Adventure Time come on and your friends
we go to very
the dog and the human the fun whenever
[Applause]
[Music]
isent is that worth
it probably not probably totally kill
the song um yay fall okay fall it is
fall it is it's
a let's get on
the the more we sing this the more
realize it's it's definitely kind of a
song that I probably wrote in a little
bit of an emo phase day or something but
it's still a nice song and you guys
really like it so I like doing it for
[Music]
you
what are we supposed to do when the best
of us turn
sour all that's been devoured by the
greedy little
[Music]
MTH I
for my own
heart for my own
dream for my own
[Music]
possibility can't you see the irony
behind the
[Music]
counter that I do
trust
[Music]
I my
own for my own
dreams for my own
possibili cuz I am
scared falling so CL
where that I don't know somewhere where
all my
vulnerabilities I will
fall for my own heart for my own dreams
for my own
possibility I am
scared a falling so low we I don't know
from where were all my
vulnerability are found
[Music]
to I don't know why I always need to end
every song with like a oh guys I
Periscope people Boop that sound
supposed to end the song boop
boop thank you
guys I'm glad you like the
[Music]
song and rafar is here hi
rafro you made it you made
it I'm glad you like the song guys
[Music]
um
right Cosmo
Javis Cosmo Javis of one
either I don't know do you want an
upbeat one we need an upbeat song don't
we I don't know why I'm giving you
options CU I'm probably just going to S
you everything
anyway let's
do Steven Universe I don't know what
that is did you paint the picture of the
fox no I didn't paint the picture of the
fox but I did make this this little Guy
this is
teror I'm going to say this so many
times in the Stream this is teror me ter
he's my buddy he's my
P
um jealous please jealous jealous
jealous why jealous or is that a song
I'm confused
now I'm
confused who is my man it's this guy
Tera Tera Terra is my
man oldj I don't know any oldj
either I don't know any of that stuff
I'm
sorry Rip Tide no sorry Bon IA or Cosmo
Javis what other song or or the the the
river by Johnny Flynn and Laura Maring
or magnet which is another one of my
songs I like I like doing
magnets magnet's good good good good oh
my gosh James I should totally see if
there's any ukar jabber the heart thing
and then the next time I I live stream
for you I'll see if I can play it that
would be awesome de the Hut song I need
write that down somewhere getet no I'll
write it down later I'm talking to you
but I all right Isaac doing it I'm a
doing
it
oh Skinny Love or the Wolves I forgot
that I could do Skinny Love let's do
Skinny Love because you guys probably
know that more than the Wolves I can do
the Wolves afterwards if you want the
wolves
[Music]
um
yeah magnet magnet magnet magnet you
guys are like magnet okay we'll do
Skinny
Love and then we'll do
magnet sound good to to you sound good
to me sound good to
everybody come on skin just
[Music]
last for a little song we never
hear
[Music]
my staring at the sink of blood and
Crush my love to W it
all cut out all the RO to let me fall
oh
moment this AR is
told and I told you to be patient and I
told you to be fine and I told you to be
balanced and I told you to be kind and
in the morning I'll be with you but it
will be a different kind and I'm holding
all the tickets and you'll be owning all
fun Come On Skinny Love what happened
[Music]
here on the and
[Applause]
[Music]
life my
mind roll so slow
on and I told you to be patient and I
told you to be fine and I told you to be
Balan and I told you to be kind and now
all you love is wasted but then who the
hell is I and I'm breaking out the
riches and at the end of all your
life who will love
you who will
fight who will
fall far
behind come on
[Music]
something like that I think the ending
needs definitely some work on it but
something like that goodbye fasel twer
thank you for thank you for for coming
and watching and enjoying and
stuff where is her violin stick City y y
That's not how you hold a violin kitus I
think I know what instrument I am
playing be cool if I could play the
violin though that would be so cool it's
a chicken flute what you guys I'm play
I'm playing the Chicken F today I hope
you enjoy it boop boop I forgot the Boop
I forgot the
Boop oh you guys are funny sorry I
forgot the poob don't shun me don't sh
me
it's a dog what are you guys talking
about it's a purse what are you talking
about are you taking the make out of my
diddy my diddy
ukulele don't small things small
things are lethal because you don't
think that we're going to hurt you I say
we because I am small I'm a small person
and I know I'm lethal okay just say it
oh bye H you have to go to sleep what
time is it where you are oh it's 7 o'
here it's nearing time for me to play
games I'm so excited I'm going to be
playing a few more songs for you guys
and then I will be live streaming for my
PlayStation and playing some games for
you I'm really excited for that cuz I
like games I super duper love your voice
thanks Florida you're super duper lovely
super super lovely you may me super
happy yeah has you look like Rose from
Titanic Adrien that is such a freaking
compliment thank you so much you know
Jam you know uh MAA Jam she tells me the
same thing that I look like the actress
and I'm like really I don't know it's
such a compliment but I I don't see it
hey can you sing sweater by yagman X I
was told it's a really good song Oh
great Turtles I tell you what the last
song I do I it will be sweater again so
I started with sweater and I will end
with sweater I seriously need to get on
with um recording recording this for you
because you guys love sweater and I love
that you love sweater because I love
sweater too and it's a good name for a
song as well I'm like I'm going to play
Sweater and You' wrote a song about a
sweater
no Thomas V Florence once we play frano
again you know what guys this is live
I'm going to tell you I have played I
have played Fano again this series is
coming back
yeah so um that's a thing and you guys
know that now
awesome hash s hours W
stream taco no not Taco Robo this is not
going to be a thing but it might be o we
could do one of those things where you
turn you know when you turn a song into
a like a 10hour version of a song we
could do that with sweater because you
do know well you know Roo that the the
the lyrics just kind of no the lyrics
the chords just go in a loop so it
totally could just go and I end the song
by the singing the beginning of the song
it could totally be
looped thinking things right now like
what oh is is Rick is Rick this is loto
yeah say hi to loto say hi to the stream
loto
[Music]
hello help me no shut
up I treat you
well
[Music]
um it's going to be green again it's
going to be green again what do you want
about it's going to be green again have
you played Uncharted 4 no oh I don't
have the game I wish I did I don't have
any money I'm seriously I'm prioritizing
my money now my money goes on new
camera and then new
pc with some games in between obviously
cuz I need to pay them for you so I kind
of you know magnet soib so so oh I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry I'm so bad at
pronouncing names Prada I will do magnet
oh Austin grubs hasn't heard sweater yet
the title makes me think of weeper
weeper does lot so smell like berries
Becca
says I don't think so but other people
tell me he does but I think I think I'm
sorry buddy I think he lost it I think
he lost it I think he's too old no one
you just lose it you get too old you
lose it he's lost it I have had
him oh my
gosh four years I've had him four
years oh I'm trying to risk the sun
without getting too much sun okay magnet
magnet magnet
magnet new hair color no it's my hair
color it's probably because I'm I'm
under a yellow light right now and so
it's probably making my hair maybe look
a bit more red than normal don't know
yeah my room's getting a bit
darker um let us smell him all right
before I press before I play magnet
enjoy the scent of um of this guy I'm
I'm showing you his belly because that's
where the scent was stored I'm not being
weird the scent was in his belly it
wasn't in his
face so don't take that the wrong way
what did you think did you sniff
[Music]
oh my God my light just
fell one
[Music]
second oh no don't say that you're
Broken Oh
brilliant d man breaks light on live
stream I can't touch that way too
[Music]
up luckily I have other
lights that
big
okay time time for my
magnet my magnet is
on Andy's like put some clothes on your
bear he needs some dignity Bears don't
wear clothes they got fur they got fur
they don't need the
clothes is the light
okay I don't think so hopefully I just
need to rescrew the bulb in but yeah I
might I possibly have just destroyed my
light oh dude when I'm gone please I
don't know it FEMA I don't know it I was
just singing it because I do like the
song I tried I'm not like the best but I
just enjoy it but I'm getting slowly
better at ukulele as every time I play
it I get a little bit better so I just
try and try and practice as much as I
can and yeah it's
good so I'm going to do magnet for you
guys magnet magnet
mag I don't know what I'm
doing
[Music]
okay
oh yeah
okay this is not a love song it's just
magne
field calling you toward me but I'm just
so
unwieldy I'm not quite sure about
soulmate but no matter how far I travel
you
gravitate towards me with a current
strong as the sea I don't know much
about we want so
[Music]
magn that day even though I
try hopelessly so
hypnotized
and I only had one wish that we could
both St
[Music]
a please don't Propel
me no matter how hard you try positive
is not our strongest side say to me that
we're meant to be as you push our ads to
be align physics do not work like that
you're no God you can't take back far
you started burnt right through so I
could no longer feel
you I don't know much
[Music]
about we were want so
magneet
since that day even though you
try you're hopelessly so
hypnotized let's just forget that wish
will never be
[Music]
attract you just repel
me
and it took me years to
[Music]
see but this is not a love song it's
just a magnetic
field ping you toward me but I'm just so
[Applause]
unwieldy that's the song about magnets
but obviously
noop lot's leaving goodbye lolat
goodbye uh Andrew Rion yagman looks very
concentrate I I do concentrate when I
when I play yeah that is a thing that
happens oh B she puts her soul on her
performance her soul is currently
penetrating her
ears that sounds so strange but I like
it a lot I really like that it's s
cool
um Can someone tell me when the video
game stream is you need to go study but
you need to see all right goodbye social
life there is no actual time for the
video game stream but looking at the
time now at 7 o'cl I'm going to play you
a couple more songs so I'll probably be
playing the games at around about let's
say 9:00 so at not to disappoint you I'd
say 9:00 would be the gaming that's
usually when I play games
anyway sun is still irritating me so
just just wants to irritate me today um
why does she boobs because Mary some
people like to say that I'm a robot and
I do this thing where I just do weird
noises I I don't like being in silence
so I'll just Boop I'll just
Boop that's my thing is a Boop
um you were so good thanks
guys thanks guys thanks guys M do a live
stream I am doing a live stream I'm
confused I'm
confused what's the best experience
you've had in your student life oh says
Sanja H that's F that's a very
interesting question the best exp I've
had of my student life cuz the reason
it's it's interesting because I'm I'm
obviously a bit older than my my fellow
student Brethren um and obviously I I
came here because I found out my passion
what I wanted to do I never I never
intended to go to the university at all
um I was working in advertising so I
didn't need to go to UNI but I'm here
because I know what I want to do I know
what I want to learn I love learning so
much um so I I kind of Happily locked
myself away sometimes and just learn
because I'm here for that and also I
really want to start my own kind of
business and this is all part of it that
makes it sound so horrible and stuff but
it is like I want I want to be able to
do things like this to make people happy
for for life and I need to start
building upon that now I take all this
very seriously so even though I do go
out on party yeah um it's not all about
that it's not why I came to
UNI um but saying that my best
experience in my uni student life was
probably actually this weekend where me
and my a lot of my uni friends and even
some other friends like Becca Becca she
might still be in the comments I finally
got to meet her she was one of my first
YouTube friends that I made when I
started my channel and we all went to to
Bright that was fun and just the people
I've made here they're they're really
lovely and yeah it's nice to be around
so many creative and intelligent people
it's totally why I went to use this get
get
um R nerd yeah I'm a nerd whatever I
don't mind I just think learning is real
fun I mean if it's something that you're
interested in obviously learning
something that you're not is annoying
that's why people in school don't enjoy
it as much but when you choose to learn
something and really you know find it
fun and you're really passionate about
it then
oops you know I'm going to shut up now
tackle's like you party every now and
then yeah yeah I like a good party I
like a good party me I like dancing
totally love dancing so how old are you
22 no
23 I just turned
23 um
yeah ah yay yay Becca's still here in
the
comments so yeah last weekend was
amazing it was so good it was so good we
went swimming as well Becca left but we
went swimming it was so so cold so
cold
um okay let me sing some more songs for
you um oh oh oh oh
oh right I haven't seen this one in a
while but it's funny it's funny to sing
um I used to sing it a lot in Periscope
but I kind of forgot it was a thing so I
might I might do it wrong but it's
really funny and it's got good meaning
to it guys it's
about kind of society and how it tells
us to look a certain way and to act a
certain way and
stuff and I just think it's all annoying
and I just get really I just don't think
you guys should worry about it because
you are who you are I I
love just imperfections and stuff that's
what who one makes is who we are and
when people think they need to be
perfect it's just like
no
no so this song is what I WOTE I I wrote
I wrote this for
[Music]
you yeah
good when your eyebrows aren't on
[Applause]
F drink his potion and your transform
into a sheep to for one's promises we
cannot keep you'll get lost you'll get
lost In This
Crowd when your hair is not on
point and you're choking on the
manufactured products in their
joints hold your ground don't be afraid
to
disappoint and let oh gosh
listen I got remember how to do
it okay guys hit the rewind
button that again when your eyebrows on
on
sleep drink this potion and you'll
transform into a sheep two for one tills
promises we cannot keep you get Just In
This
Cloud when your hair is not on
point and you're choking on the
manufactured products in their
joint hold your ground don't be afraid
to
disappoint and listen to this
[Music]
sound it's your brain that makes you you
drives me in saying to see what you're
put
through it's your quirks that make you
you don't need to change no need to how
to you're just you and I'm just
[Music]
me when that th up hi clear
buy our food Replacements half price for
the first year side effects sometimes
include explosions of one's rear results
are sure
toand when an absence that your twiice
your
age get back to the gym without tight
skin you're just a waste have you
considered surgery will clone the
perfect face you'll never have to we
take that function
away it's your brain that makes to you
drive me
insan to see what you put
through it's your qus that make you you
don't need to change no need to
[Music]
out you're just you and I'm just me and
we're so
perfectly
[Music]
unique cuz it's your PR that makes to
you dust me
insan to see what you put through yeah
it's your quir that make you you don't
need to change no need to out
just keep
[Music]
being wo that's that
song it's All About yeah not not needing
to change don't worry about having a
fire gap or fleeking on flicking
fleeking on the eyebrows fleeked just be
you I'm so sure it's a trumpet you guys
are so strange what are you talking
about it's great I've got an eyelash in
my
eye it's a chicken with one leg it's a
bird top three sweater four and this oh
really you like it that much Manta thank
you thank you so much I'm glad you like
this
one uh I like that too James James is
like I like that there's mistakes in the
song about not being perfect yes exactly
and that's the whole I think that's what
this channel was all about you know just
do what makes you happy don't worry
about failing everyone fails it's
totally fine failing is fine failing is
the first step to
success thanks guys I'm glad you liked
it thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you I don't know what I'm doing anymore
um
Robo wants sweater but sweater is going
to be the last song So if you want
sweater that means that it's coming up
to the end so do you want sweater are
you sure about that are you sure about
that great Turtles I love how yag
doesn't understand anything we're saying
no that's very true that's very true
sometimes I just get really
confused Andy oh no she got a septic eye
I did I got I got something in my eye
right I'm going to go get this thingy
out of my eye cuz it's going to really
annoy me and then I will come back and
play you a couple more songs and then
you can help me de a game for later on
is this like you're literally hanging
out with me for the day so cool and my
friends cuz of FR was here so cool I
wonder guys do you think the sun's going
to like us now yes this is good I can
handle that that of
sun yeah all right I'll be back I'm
walking
oh I might as well put on the other
thing I know let's see what you guys
have been saying on
Twitter
while I was gone I attempted to fix my
light and it didn't it didn't fix didn't
fix guys oh well I broke my light this
is this is brilliant just
brilliant whoa someone just put a little
a little mo rat thing up on the Twitter
thing I'll show
you
how funny is that that's quite funny I
like
it okay what you got saying hey guys
it's out of my
eye it's 2:16 a.m. where bronchitis is
bronchitis you're not going to get any
sleep you're going to be all tired
tomorrow well if you got nothing to do
tomorrow then fair enough fair enough
but I'm sorry if you if you get tired
tomorrow no it didn't fix it didn't
[Music]
fix anyway wait stop making noises let's
actually
sing Pikachu she can't hear you what is
Pikachu trying to talk to me this is
crazy this is a Dre come true guys this
is a a drink and
true I'm going to sing Cosmo Javis for
you because I really want to and it's
really upbeat and I feel like All I Do
Is Sing You songs about sadness and you
get all tired and sad and I don't just
want to do that to you so I'm going to
sing you this song which is quite
upbeat and I think you like
it if I should see you in the
sky I will look up I will look up with
some
Delight I'll probably ask you should
you've heard a million times how many
parts of things I do would you consider
crying I'll ask you which way I should
go even if you answer I trust you in my
soul I'm only human and I watch stories
on TV they give me an ending when an
ending All I
[Music]
Need You don't know how much I love
this you don't know how much I
[Music]
love many lines of hads to
cross don't want to belong to a club
with such
aient get your ass down here reprimand
me for my sin have can out no reason
it's no reasons why
I how come every man ain't
good if it happened overnight would you
Tire if you could I believe in heaven
and I deny myself death dying keeps me
conscious of the way I waste my
breath you don't know how much I love
this you don't know how much I love this
you don't know how much I love that you
don't know how much I love
so you'll tell me how it
is what if how it is just not agree with
how I live should I admit the path I'm
on is not the best should I join your
super highway cuz you say that it's
correct just want an answer I can
trust things I should be doing ain't the
same as things I must Tony so is the
teacher I
respect he's always been there when I
take a nasty
[Music]
step you don't know how much I love this
you don't know how much I love this you
don't know how much I love this you
don't know how
I
[Music]
love so I don't think we should conf
first let's just grab a cup of coffee
get betray if you
prer you're look at me ways that I've
never looked at you and I'll set back
you're wondering what you're thinking I
should
do you don't know how how much I love it
you don't know how much I love it you
don't know how much I love it you don't
know how much I
love
yes Boop end of the
song that song's so intense my fingers
always like just goes it's so
fast is she blind obviously she can see
yeah I can see but I can't I can't read
so soe I can't read and sing at the same
time I'm not a very good multitasker I I
I do try to read your comments but then
I realized that I'm going to mess up the
song and I'm like nope nope nope got to
stop got to stop got to
stop anyone else you can't sit still
while hearing this music thanks Victor
I'm glad to hear you shaking chicken you
little
booty laia has that was a mole rat oh
the picture was a mole rat that's
cool L by bright eyes I don't know L by
Bright Eyes I'm sorry gray Turtles I'm
going to have to make a list of songs
that I need to learn that you guys keep
on requesting so that I can play I can
play them f
f
Victor are you lying to me L I did
not I don't trust him
anymore thanks RMA for the birthday
message thank you so much read singing
is hard bronius it I don't I don't know
if anyone can do it if they can do it
then I think they're they're very they
an amazing multi multi what do I think
about
Portugal I
actually my mom is moving to Portugal my
mom is moving to Portugal this September
so that's what I think of Portugal I've
never been there seems very hot uh but
yeah apparently properties are very
cheap over there so my mom likes it a
lot H thanks alerson for saying that my
singing is Splendid Robo she's scared of
loto now I am no that's all right he
would never hurt me I I know he
wouldn't Define your purple
mant
what what my
ukulele what I'm so
confused Bonitas you going with her no
I'm not going to I'm not going to
Portugal Portugal is way too hot for me
I'll go over there to visit my mom but
I'm not going to live in Portugal I like
English I I quite enjoy English weather
that's a weird thing to say I know but I
like the cold
I love wear baggy baggy jumpers you know
coming in on a cold day and having a
nice warm shower and then getting in bed
and sitting by the fire having hot
chocolates I'm all about that lifestyle
so England's pretty good for me um where
did you learn how to play in my room yep
in my room I'm still learning I'm not
that good I'm still learning but yeah I
just I'm one of those learners where I
don't go step by step I just kind of
skip that and just try and learn songs
that I want to learn cuz I found I did
try and do tutorials on YouTube but I
got viable very quickly hey Asam sorry
for your late arrival gives yagman her
secret potato gift thank you for the
gift ASM I put it down here no worries
thanks for coming I don't mind how late
you come it's just awesome that you're
coming oh you're
here
yagman Florida is Sleepy would you
kindly say good night to her it will
make her sleep oh okay bye Florida where
are you in the comments goodbye good
night goodbye good night goodbye good
night good night goodbye goodbye good
night ah people are are trying to sleep
all right does this mean that I should
probably end the live stream then um
with sweater or I could sing you Boniva
Boniva then sweater cuz Boniva is a
really good one to send me to sleep B IA
always sends me to sleep when I play B
IA just saying B IA sends me to
sleep Ro Le music by the internet as
well yeah the internet's good cuz you
don't have to pay for anything and it's
good I like rain every now and then but
not too often says manad yeah I don't
know I'm not taking on the rain but I
like I like the cold I like the Chilly
Winds and stuff I do like that
one
so let's sing Bon over for the people
who are going to
sleep I know I just Skinny Love so I'm
going to do wolves the Wolves the Wolves
I like saying this song it's really easy
and just very chill it's a very chill
[Music]
song
somay my
pain somay my pain will like
you Hest your
[Music]
play Hest your flame and walk
through the
world
around
you
in the morning I'll call
[Music]
you all is my
game all is my game it's just
[Music]
you doing what your
crane swing R your Crane and run me
through and the
story all over
[Music]
you in the morning I'll call
you can't you find a
CO
[Music]
when your eyes are all
painted what have
[Music]
been what might
friend What Might Have Been Love
don't B
me what might have
been
[Music]
don't Someday My
Pain Someday My
[Music]
Pain Boop end of the
song
F Yas will Periscope after the stream BR
bro I never told you that this is false
information boy I mean I might do but
there's no certainty but I will
definitely be doing a gaming stream
later on tonight through my PlayStation
which will be on YouTube gaming it'll be
right here I'm doing this through
YouTube gaming as well believe it or not
um
that's is not a guitar no it's not a
guitar oh so ha said GI me this guitar
I'm sorry not guitar it probably looks
like a guitar in my tiny hands
whoop whoop I
see
what we should have a band be so cool
interet bands interet band I've never
been in a band before be
cool so cool
game
stream 10 would record and play it on
repeat a thanks relli you guys are so
cute you're so cute are you getting
bored of this singing live stream now
are you are
you or me with my head in the air
singing at you like this I've always put
my head in the air don't like so
annoying so
annoying
spoiler alert this is great heral yagman
X is a robot that have taken over this
Channel and she will stream forever
robots needs robots need uh recharging
as well though I have you know so that
may not happen unless I can recharge and
stream maybe that's the thing maybe that
could
happen uh Schrock P this guy is Terri
and he's from one of my latest videos
called who is terara if you want to
watch it I would say watch it before you
go to bed it's a creepy bedtime story
and I I love it I'm so happy with I'm so
happy with it I'm so happy Thomas is
like I'm never going to get bored
everyone's like I'm never going to get
bought the mysterious L the mysterious L
that's a puty name is never going to get
bought either neither's chance ptle
neither's Bon kitus NE so NE there wait
no Andy just said
wgf
um you're brilliant pray for Grandma
what do you want about a said pray for
Grandma what do you want
about
um Nina Nina lucky is never getting
bored thanks guys you're so cute you're
so cute but I think I'm going to have to
get to the end of the stream because
also the lighting is not that good
anymore it's not as good as it was when
it started so how
about two more songs maybe two one of
mine oh wait yeah we're going to do
sweater as
well so I'm going to sing you this one
which is another one of
mine I don't know what this one's called
either I need to think of names for
[Music]
them I'm already I'm already humming
sweat and then I'll have a little chat
with you before we go but then I oh yeah
because you need to help me choose my my
game that I'm going to be playing okay
guys you can't leave me you're not
allowed well you can but
[Music]
whatever I've been peing through the
crowd
[Music]
pastes that I seal so long
ago I never thought I would
surpass barricades stuck me in
the stay inside and lock the
[Music]
door can't you see it's nothing
more I told myself it was a
lie
that I was never meant to
[Music]
fly and now he's kind of seeping through
the walls that wreck me up my water
floors and maybe I should run or maybe I
should catch
[Music]
some warning signs of peing by
revealing what I lost so long
ago convin myself it was a
TR but you reach out your hand and I
follow come outside and lock the
door can't you see there so much
more we tell ourselves that it's a
lie that we always meant to
fly and now these kind of sleeping
through the walls that break me up my
water flows maybe I should run or maybe
I should
[Music]
catch
catch i' oh I've been peering through
the crowd
from past you I se so long
[Music]
ago imagine
go little bit little bit booping boops
little bit
of boops at the end where is my words
today they they I'm rting back to robot
form have you guys
no uh yay Yasin would be a horrible
drummer
oh how do you know I could be amazing
you don't
know you don't
knowed strike is bro strike strike it
bro blue Army blue Army blue Army blue
arm what's the blue AR what's the blues
about what's the blues
about
fly you guys are funny you really laugh
how much did that piano cost you guys
it's not a
piano it cost me
£20 so yeah it's quite a cheap one I've
proba to get a new one but that's
definitely on my way down on my list of
priorties of things that I need to buy
for you guys to make these absolutely
awesome I mean we're still doing them
which is amazing but I want to make the
quality o and one day it will be o right
up right up
then hey Yasmin pie Yasmin
pie but Yasmin pie are you trying to say
like cutie pie because no she can she
only she can be she she's freaking
awesome she's
awesome no don't worry bro you didn't
you didn't hurt my feelings it's cool we
I know I know you playing I know you
messing it's cool I think I I think I've
gotten to know you a little bit now from
from our little live
stream I'm getting to know who you are
as people if is your hair red my hair is
I don't know it looks very red on here
at the moment because of the lighting I
think but it's yeah I guess it's like a
bit ready brownie orangey I don't know a
bit of
everything do you play any other
instruments nope oh actually the
recorder so
yes but that's back that's back at
home20 why you didn't bought unshaded
for because I bought this
like a year ago and then CH 4 wasn't out
a year ago she can do makeup I can do
makeup I
try I look at oh you talking about
CutiePie yeah I actually look at people
like CutiePie to do my makeup because
I'm like how do I do this makeup thing
and then I watch YouTube and I'm like oh
that's how you do it that's
cool um I have started watching
PewDiePie and try to for gameplay gray
Turtles I would I started watching it
this morning he's good he's good I do I
do like his gameplay
videos um reene re re reene
calie
manaloto a said hi to you I'm sorry if I
didn't say your name right though I have
a feeling I probably didn't say your
name right oh my gosh guys I just saw
something over on the Twitter feed let
me leave you alone for just a second so
we can all Marvel in the glory of this
this
picture that is absolutely
terrifying oh here we go back to this
one look how cool that is I'm in Doctor
Who
guys I so wish I was that's an awesome
awesome thing thank
you thank you guys that's
amazing oh so
so I read your name but you said if you
can I don't know if I can I don't know
if I was doing it very well jalam this
stream has been going on for I don't
know how long has this stream been going
on for guys like quite a while
yeah um I don't know I'll let you I'll
let you
um I'll let you have a little look at
that oh my gosh it's been going on for 4
hours and a half I think it's time to to
wrap up don't you should we wrap up this
stream alexen she's still there
I'm still here I'm still
here I haven't left my room all
day I haven't maybe I should go outside
should I go outside today what do you
think maybe I should go
outside nah I was out all
weekend that's good enough for me I
don't need to go
outside
my name said we've been streaming for
2.3 hours you maybe overall with the
breaks it would be something like that
actually like two and a half hours or
maybe three hours with the break but
everyone else why is assd keep on saying
pray for Grandma I'm so
confused I'm just so confused right
now
enjoy the rainless day actually it's
going to be rainless all week and it has
been rainless for ages so you know I
have been enjoying it I went to Brighton
bright oh guys if you're if you live
near Brighton or if you live in England
you need to go because I love it so much
though I really want to I really want to
move there can someone can someone pay
for a house for me no actually I want to
live on a boat I want to live on a boat
do improv ukulele oh chiso improv
ukulele okay okay let's do this right
I've got to I've got to be um in the
zone what do I want to sing about it's
my birthday let's sing about my
[Music]
birthday I'm just doing the full song
really fast like it's my birthday it's
it's my birthday but it's not because I
love it's my birthday but it's not my
birthday and I don't even
know what to say but I'm happy that
you're
here yes I'm happy that
here and I'm having a live stream with
my favorite were people trying some
Japanese cabbage stuff and it was
weird but I quite liked
it but I could have finished
it and I don't know how to sing to this
song because I don't know what my
fingers are doing they're just making
cord and I'm hoping I can sing for
you cuz you all
ring
ah let's move on to a different sentence
cuz I don't really know what I was going
to
say and I hope you're okay cuz you are
great and I want to share with
you some
cake cuz cake is life cake is life and
Cake it's but a
lie and I think I'm going to end it
there there you go improv lady that
was weird
there is no other word for
it you clearly
stunning yeah I don't you know you know
that was my improv ukul lady it was cool
cake is life but cake is birth Al liive
philosophical philosophical right
there Freddy's like what's happening I
was doing some mucle improv which is
basically me just mashing whatever and
singing whatever I did one one video of
it on my channel maybe I should do more
but I don't know because sometimes I do
them and it's like what is that why why
did I sing that what did I just
saying oh cake oh
cake I'm glad you like it cake is
strange life is
strange but I Pissed My Pants and so did
[Music]
you I don't quite know why you did too
but you did to poo and it may me feel a
bit less like poo I don't know why why
would I sing that why did that come out
of my head I love it though it was funny
it was funny nuul improv is best
improv thanks I'm glad I'm glad you
appreciate I'm glad you appreciate hey
Romy of course I missed you we all
missed you didn't
we was like don't be like that okay
maybe Robo didn't miss
you I don't know I'm not going to get
involved in this I'm going to carry on
to a different conversation ah there you
go Robo miss you Robo miss you Robo Miss
Robbie
Robie I just said Robbie I just shipped
you guys I didn't mean to do that sorry
or maybe I did do you want me to there
you go
Robbie what car do you drive um I used
to have a little Fiesta um I can't tell
you the exact make or anything but it
was four doors and my my dad did it up
my dad used to be a racing car driver
did you guys know that no you probably
didn't so he did he did up the engine
for me and it was it was pretty awesome
the acceleration on the thing was good
and they used to drive on dartmore at
night and it was amazing and there's so
much folklore around dartmore but don't
get me started about folkore because I
love folkore so
much so many interesting folkore
around um Christo wants me to do more
impro ukul lady what do what do you guys
think you like that
um can you do a thing where you sing
what we write in the chat great terl
that's a good idea all right let's do it
I'm just going to play whatever comes to
my head I'm not going to say this is
going to be good but I'm going to try
for you guys cuz this is a good
idea I'm sorry Shambo go study turn me
off stop watching stop
it definitely do more in
what time is it there say rain yay I
guess says
Ramy dang my dad was cool say taco
blacko and jelly jam I think it's jelly
yam that is the best
ever Alex
super twist ending
and Robo says this song is
awful thanks man that hurts my
soul does your dad like Formula One says
Andy yes he does my dad loves Formula
[Music]
1 I love great Turtles he is the best
says great Turtles Sor great
T I ruin that for you didn't I how dare
you Robo how Dare You Robo says
alason how dare you
Robo and taco likes flos I mean Taco
likes tacos and Thomas V Flores is up at
3:00
a.m. and the rain is but the sky crying
says Manas that's very deep you know and
my name is the best says my
name feddie thinks this is amazing and
mysterious lemon is going see you yman
see you mysterious
lemon but chocolate will always be there
for you says
Nina just remember the cake his life say
Andy and Francisco Min now rain will
wash
away
everything
laia just keep doing this please Str up
his back
bronchitis bang FCO likes curtains and
Ry likes
trains and Jim Hawk says this is amazing
what Wesker Albert this song is cool
keep it coming great ha I can't wait
forever I'm not that patient I've got
too many things to do I wonder where
that's
from Yas his comment who the song says I
and bomy is laughing out
loud boo what the hell boo what the hell
how is it yellow says
Romy and Al thinks I'm
lying and
alide says dou the morning to your lotes
Json
happy birthday yes thanks and I want to
travel around the world says
Joan I can't say names so I
apologies I'm the B one so you
[Music]
Cano literally throwing random words say
Romy I'm potato shall rule all we are
all submit to its
powers oh my God she didn't recognize
her own lyric says great Turtles I did
though I did though I did though I did
though and boil them mash them sck them
in a
stew oh God says Boon kitus Isaac this
is awesome Felix somebody told me Alex
this is hilarious vict and I don't know
what happened in great Turtles your SM
concealed the secret it's so sickly
sweet that I can't see the point b e a
u
and that was fun I enjoy that that was
good but now I'm actually going to play
for you and I'm going to go U well no we
need to choose my my game first then I'm
going to go have a little rest you guys
should have a rest too and those of you
who are studying you need to study and
at least have an hour off to study
before I start streaming again say
cheese you guys are so funny ra Ravi the
fs did not move stop it guys the player
with my playing with my mind cre me out
here
Rob is like we're tricking to singing
sweater yes you are and I am going to
sing sing sweater for you now because I
know you've been waiting for it and I
said this is how we're going to end the
stream actually should we should we
decide on um let's decide on the no no
we'll sing sweater then we'll decide the
game okay yagman stick to what you
originally said St changing your
mind you ready for
this get comfy you comfy you
comfy are you comfy though
[Music]
good I can't wait forever not that
patient
[Music]
many when out I
won't
[Music]
mhm smile conceals a secret and it's a
snake PE sweet that I can't see the
point of diing
deeper to the surface that is just so
beautiful I don't want to spoil your
[Music]
soul please don't leave this to go
cold your eyes make me feel dizzy when
you quiz me on my childhood hisory I'll
share with you if you so kindly cut me
so I
[Music]
can I could prry through the C so
crudely Glu you straight on
but instead I enjoy this you that so
shallowly
and I don't want to spoil my
soul please don't leave this to cold if
the best things are worth waiting for
would you disagree would you only
see but is what we both are and I'm too
afraid to turn around and see how
far and see how
far I can't wa forever I'm not that
patient I've got too
many like aweater
when sun comes out I won't
be
Last Song of the live stream
sad
sad but I'm starting to get dizzy you
know when you talk too much and you get
dizzy you're
like that's how I
feel she will when she gets a new mic
yeah Manas I will record this when I get
the new mic because then it'll be a
proper recording I'm so excited I'm so
excited I'm so excited
so excited anyway
um uh Andy says he's never been this
long on YouTube before thank you Andy
for staying so long this is a very long
live stream so I really love all of you
guys that have stayed or even just
popped in you're amazing thanks for
thanks for sharing this wonderful day
with me so thank you thank you thank you
thank you Thomas Villa Flores now we get
a fck a game you do right let me
um let me what game is what games have I
got so I could play for you I could play
zombie
again uh yeah I could play zombie again
for you I could play alien isolation
again for you I could play The Evil
Within hey let's make this a Twitter
poll shall we shall we now yeah that's a
good idea um
I could also I I think I've got
some what other games have I
got I got Broken Age but I'm already
halfway through that game so I don't
know if I really want to start again
with
it whatever
G I got Batman but I've already finished
the
story so I don't know how well that
would
go zombie is great says
Robo but Robo also wants to see the
alien again H hard isn't it
uh people are saying
zombie oh no worries Manas no worries if
you can't see the
[Music]
game oh
no
[Music]
play Five Nights at Freddy's stuff no I
can't I'm playing on my um PlayStation 4
so I'm going to do a little um little
Twitter paw right
now and see what what games you guys
would like me to play I mean I could
actually turn on my PlayStation cuz I
know I've got I've got some um what's
the worded oh I've got Fallout as well I
haven't play Fallout in bloody forever
um but I know part of me wants to play
zombie again cuz zombie was so much fun
when we played it together it would be
really good actually wasn't it but then
also alien isolation is even within so
horror games obviously but you know
maybe you guys are sick of horror you
sick of horror
maybe signing on the
PlayStation let's do what can
pleasey John PlayStation knows my
face twiter p twiter p time yes it will
be zombie The Last of Us alien
isolation wait not The Last of Us sorry
I don't have I why is that do I still
have it in
my no okay sorry that wasn't my disc for
some reason PlayStation's still saying I
could play it I got really happy then I
thought I was going to play the last of
us but nope I don't have it I'm very
sorry about that um I could play Grim
Fandango
um Broken Age I guess I could start
again or start from where I'm from if
you guys like that
game um yeah or I guess there's Batman
but there's no point playing the
campaign again CU I've already played it
so let me
do do I not have any I thought I had
more
games I've got little little games I've
got grow
home I've got Super Meat
Boy I'm really bad at Super Meat Boy
though got skulls of the Shogun I don't
even know what that
is oh I've got everybody's gone to the
Rapture as well I never finished that
game I got halfway through it and never
finished it I don't have uncharged I'm
sorry play whatever you
have that's very true sad because you
won't enjoy it if if I'm not enjoying it
that's very true very true but I will
still put a little Twitter thingy
Twitter poll up so you guys can see it
I'll do that after I stop this stream
you don't want to watch me making a poll
but yeah I'll do a poll if you want to
vote for what I play later on tonight
then look on my Twitter account there
will be a poll on there you can vote for
what you want to
see let's turn off the PlayStation
noises yeah so you can you can see what
you want to see or let me know what you
want to see and your vote will will
account for something anyway I'm going
to go now I'm going to try and recharge
my batteries my docking station is over
there so I got to should I be one and um
yeah I will see you later thank you so
much for being a part of this it's been
an amazing live stream I'm just going to
sit here and wait for you guys to catch
up with me so I can say goodbye to you
properly and
yeah po Paulo what I heard you code
what's your favorite language I don't
know to be honest I just told him
whatever whatever suits me best I quite
I quite like JavaScript and stuff stuff
because I started off as a web developer
so and jQuery plugins are life saers so
good um isri when will you make a public
appearance so we can hug
you I don't know well is is anyone going
to some in the city actually before I go
are you going to some in the city do you
know what it is it's a London YouTube
event I'm thinking of going um I'm not
very big or well known in the in the
YouTube scene so I I'll be buying
tickets and I don't know if you know if
if I'll be able to get a panel or or
anything like that to meet you guys but
maybe I can make my own maybe screw it
maybe I can just make my own little
cardboard bit and put a science in yag
my neck and I can dress up as a robot
and you guys would know it was me so
we'll we'll see what happens I'm I'm
looking in the comments to see if any of
you are going summ this let me know if
you do tweet me let me know now whatever
it'll be cool to know how many of you
guys would actually be there cuz I'm
kind of iffing and amming about whether
I want to go or
not rafo take me with you to some of the
city maybe if I go Rao that would be
awesome I need friends CU I don't have
many friends I do I do I just don't know
many people in the YouTube sphere sphere
so um I get really nervous I'm doing
this already this is what I do when I
get nervous I get nervous when I meet a
lot of people that I don't know oh scary
times but I will go if you guys are
there because I think it'll be amazing
to meet you guys properly it'll be
awesome um J Jos says you can go if it's
not too late awesome well go on the
summer of the city website I'm pretty
sure it's not too late I I'm pretty sure
last year this the tickets were selling
right up to kind of a few weeks before
the event and the event is if I'm right
July or something like that so you still
got a couple of months oh tack of FL is
in the US I wish I could go to to vidon
or as you know I don't know about VidCon
it's too big it's scary maybe
packs packs would be amazing that would
be awesome but anyway um dreaming I'm
just dreaming here meet what where I'm
btis in summ of the city which is a
London YouTube kind of gathering event
thing and I don't know if anyone's going
to be going to it um I was just going to
ask you guys if you were
going come over to
renberg Alex
Alex maybe I want I want to travel a lot
more so you never know I could end up
there one day so Hib is sleeping in two
minutes time good idea where and when
again it's somewhere in the city
somewhere in the city guys um I'll tweet
about it afterwards I'll just say
remember let me know if you're going to
somewhere in the city and then you guys
can tweat me back wasn't the stream
ending yeah it was Asad I just I just
get very very easily um distracted by by
you guys I don't like not replying to
you because you got so many questions
but yeah will we talking again I do live
streams all the time so it's fine it's
fine he's sleeping in one minute so he
sleeping in one minute okay um I'm going
to
go I'm going to go I'm going to put on
Twitter the the voting polling thing
vote if you want to vote thank you very
much for watching it has been amazing
have a lovely day or evening and I will
see you I'm going to say now halfast 9
cuz this has gone on way longer than I
thought and I do need to recharge but I
will be back I'll be playing a game for
you and it's going to be fun I'll see
you later have a lovely day or evening
if I don't see you later
on I've got to get it I'm going to shout
out names and Say Goodbye To You by laet
by so who's sleeping probably right now
by bronius by great Arles by mantis by
Roo by adamist by Thomas Flores by Roo
Again by James of course games by
Christo by Isaac by Nar girl. exe Like
It by sad Batman oh sad Batman by
Muhammad by Assad by Ivon by salad
killer salad
Killer by um by Steven Georgio by antie
Potato by
ponal um by great turtles by alakus I
think I'm going to end up just going
around in circles here I think I've said
everyone I think I've said everyone that
I can goodbye goodbye goodbye we Albert
goodbye goodbye goodbye it's me Fab
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye